DSX is one of the most important series
of all time not just from a mechanical
perspective but from a narrative one as
well its gameplay would make it one of
the early pioneers of the immersive sim
a genre of games bent on giving the
player multiple routes and options to
tackle any given situation allowing them
to play how they want without ever
feeling like their style is invalid from
a story perspective however it's a game
whose narrative has only gotten more
relevant with time from government
coverups and corrupt officials to
discrimination and bigotry thex explores
all these topics with impressive form
and it's this part that I want to focus
on today I want to take you through the
story of DSX and both critique analyze
and discuss it along the way it's a
series of many highs and lows sometimes
even in the same game but at its core
DSX has a lot to say about the world and
I have a lot to say about it so without
further Ado like the video if you enjoy
and subscribe for more content like this
feel free to watch my other videos which
are similar in style to this one but on
a variety of games in series and as
always let's get
started the original DSX first began
development in 1997 and was built on a
dream waren Spectre the director behind
the game wanted to make a very
particular game one where Choice was
King one where the player could play how
they wanted and still reach the end it
would be what he called a real world
roleplaying game unfortunately the tech
wasn't there in the early to mid '90s so
he worked on an impressive catalog of
other titles like Ultima underworld
thief and System Shock hoping that one
day he could see his dream game through
frustrated with his employment at
Looking Glass he sought employment
elsewhere at Electronic Arts until of
all people John Romero the OG of the FPS
genre offered him a spot at his company
ion storm stating that he'd be able to
make his dream game without any
restrictions that game was DSX the
inspiration for DSX came from all places
Warren's wife who was fascinated by the
X Files growing tired of the typical
fantasy settings he wanted to create
something that would blend his love of
player choice with a realistic setting
what set DSX further apart from its
other contemporaries was its focus on
conspiracies Spectre wanted to take
popular conspiracies from around the
world and not only make them true but
spin them in a way that made sense one
such example is the Illuminati to many
there is a conspiracy that there is a
shadow organization that are the true
rulers of the world due to them
controlling the governments of the world
through literal power or blackmail thex
takes this and makes it true as the
Illuminati not only exists within the
game world but we also get to meet
various members of the team and even
work together to defeat Majestic 12 they
too are also filled with their own kind
of conspiracy as Majestic 12 often
shorten to mj12 is believed to be a
group of people who were involved in the
cleanup and recovery of alien spacecraft
it started in the 1980s when British
ufologist a title I just learned existed
named Timothy good claimed to be in
possession of 1950s era UFO documents in
them were the names of 12 individuals
ranging from Military Officers to
government officials and secret
scientists all who helped recover UFOs
across the US thus the Majestic 12 it
picked up a lot of steam during the same
time when the famous Roswell UFO
incident was re-examined as many people
believe that it wasn't a military
balloon that crashed like the government
said but rather an extraterrestrial
aircraft DX doesn't go as deep on the
UFO side as the real Majestic 12 but
that's due to them being wrapped up in
the game's own conspiracy still you
could see how this is different when
compared to other games of the time not
just ones in the immersive Sim genre and
I think that's a large reason for the
game's success it was not only a
completely original idea for the early
2000s but it also prayed on people's
love for a good conspiracy while it
focus is mainly on conspiracies it's
also a game about corporate corruption
and greed all together in a
multi-layered story filled with
unreliable narrators and fake news
gojima rightfully gets credit for
creating Metal Gear Solid 2 a game that
is more relevant now than it was when it
first released but I don't see nearly
enough praise for war ins Spectre doing
the same thing just a year before Sons
of Liberty all of this one put together
makes for a rather compelling narrative
in fact it reminds me a lot of the 1999
film The Matrix as in that movie one of
the characters Morpheus talks to the
main protagonist Neo by taking two
different colored pills the catch is is
that one pill will send him back to
reality like nothing happened with the
other allowing him to go further down
the rabbit hole this scene is a perfect
representation of DSX and is the best
way to convey what the games are about
without actually talking about its
events DSX is in a way its own kind of
conspiracy as the further you go the
weirder it gets it starts off quite tame
where we work as an agent fighting
against terrorists only for it to come
crumbling down in just a few short
missions as we find out that the group
we work for is not only lying to us but
is getting their own strings pulled from
the Shadows by a group of people who
want to rule the world it's a rabbit
hole that gets increasingly more bizarre
the further you go but there is a sense
that there is an ending to all this and
that once you come out the other side
youve discovered the real story all
there is required of the player is to
take the first step and fall to the Deep
Chasm that is this game story so let's
do it the game's whole plot starts with
the real Sucker Punch to audiences
nowadays by stating that the world is
being ravaged by a worldwide plague
called the gray death with a vaccine
called Ambrosia being distributed to
help Quil the effects of the plague just
like our own virus the people of the
world also needed frequent doses in this
casee monthly injections or the end up
Contracting it this poses a large
problem for the UN and the governments
of the world is not only do they need to
make enough for everyone but they need
to keep making more if the human race
has any chance of surviving this
pandemic naturally there isn't enough to
go around but many middle and lower
class people are starting riots and
fights over this stuff not just because
the world has turned into a sort of
doggy dog world but many also believe
that not only is the government hoarding
vials of Ambrosia for themselves but
that they were the ones who made the
virus in the first place talk about an
accusation for as much as I will praise
the writing and premise of this game
though it's one fault is lack of
subtlety the opening crawl shows two
people named Bob pagee and Walter Simons
who are without question the most
villainous people possible both of them
are pleased to hear that a US senator
was infected with this virus and when
asked if he accepted the vaccine Bob
Page claimed that it was almost pathetic
how quickly he wanted to be cured
following This Walter informs Paige that
riots are breaking out across the city
over the poor distribution of the
vaccine to which he says why contain it
let it spill over to the schools and
churches Let the Bodies pile up in the
streets in the end they'll beg us to
save them while Walter is not as obvious
about his intentions he is complacent in
Bob PA's comments implying that he
agrees with him Majestic 12 the group
that Bob pagee is a part of and the one
that Walter is allied with also has a
logo of a hand over the Earth basically
implying that they want the world and
the palm of their hand I cannot imagine
that anyone was meant to assume they
have any kind of new wants to them as
they make it clear within the first cut
scene of the game before the player even
gets a chance to shoot at somebody that
they're the bad guys I'm unsure whether
I should condemn this choice or praise
it though as while the characters
themselves are as black and white as you
can get their actions and motivations
are where that gray area comes from why
they're doing this how they want to go
about enacting this plan and the methods
the other guys used to stop them create
enough Nuance to where it's better to
just not trust anyone at all it's a
peculiar style of Storytelling one that
had me confused for a time is the game
had set itself up to be about conspiracy
and how not everything is as it says it
was yet right in its opening moments it
throws up a big neon sign that says word
the bad guys although in all fairness
mixing enough black and white together
will create Shades of Gray following
that scene the player can start playing
we play as JC Denton a nano augmented
soldier who just joined unaco a
coalition of people who were hired to
fight back against International
terrorism they were originally conceived
of thanks to an attack on Liberty Island
due to this the group also set up its
main headquarters on that island right
near the coast the reason we're here is
because the terrorists called the NSF
have attacked one of the government
ships of Ambrosia so we're going to
infiltrate the base question the leader
and find the missing shipment DX wastes
no time not only getting the player into
the action but also letting them
experience it for themselves the whole
island has essentially become a
playground for the player to experiment
with which is where that play how you
want model that war ins Spectre and
vision comes in while I won't spend too
much time talking about the gameplay
systems and various changes made to the
gameplay within the series it's worth at
least explaining what the genre is and
how that impacts the story DX is
considered an immersive Sim which might
be one of the hardest genres to actually
Define as what sets that genre a apart
from the rest is not something
mechanical like a point of view but
rather a variety of complex systems that
other games use but these in particular
use more Spectre wrote a Manifesto of
sorts on DSX and I think this one part
where he describes the game's principles
is a wonderful summarization of the
whole genre he says problems not puzzles
no forced failure players do NPCs watch
and areas of multiple entries and exit
points while a great statement it could
still be confusing to understand so I
often just mention the games that are
considered immersive Sims rather than
explain what they do the popular of the
bunch include System Shock Thief DSX pre
2017 Dishonored and quite a few more
these principles though allow the
gameplay to not only flourish on its own
but also uplift the story along the way
giving the player the freedom to choose
how they want lets them essentially
create their own story take mission 2
for example in Hell's Kitchen in a back
alley there's a woman named Sandra who's
being cornered by a man named Johnny if
you decide to intervene she will thank
you and give you a passcode that opens
the door to Smuggler an arms dealer he
has his own string of interactions where
he could save his buddy for to get a
discount on some of his items which then
turns into an investigation as to why
there's a base of soldiers underneath
the streets of New York City who also
claim to know JC Sandra on the other
hand will then get into a fight with her
father in a later Mission over a guy
named Jojo fine the next in line for the
joar family presumably JoJo has had
quite the Bizarre Adventure by being the
city's pimp and one of his girls is
Sandra her dad wants to confront him but
doing so has the two get into a shootout
he isn't packing any heat though and
we'll die if we don't arm him ourselves
depending on what occurs here Sandra
will either stay with her dad at the
hotel or skip town only to be found
homeless at a gas station thanks to
getting robbed at gunpoint all of this
starts with you deciding whether or not
to help her in this moment What's even
more impressive is that this idea is
carried throughout the whole game in
much smaller and more immediate ways
like alternate routes and boss fights
talking to this kid and giving him food
will provide JC with a code that lets
him enter an NSF base through the back
and the bosses some of which are our
allies can also be killed in multiple
ways and at different times agent
andavar for example can be killed here
in Mission 3 which as a reward will give
the player information on JC's birth and
his purpose of then newco refusing to
kill her here gives you the option to
kill her in Mission four but that's a
pretty difficult mission on its own as
you have to survive a section that is
intended for you to die her last
location is in mission five which has
its own unique method of delivering
death as you could search the computers
of unaco to find her kill phrase which
with spoken kills her skipping the fight
entirely however Anna is unfortunately
the exception and not the rule here as
the other bosses Walter and Gunther
don't have nearly as many options Walter
especially as he doesn't have a kill
phrase of his own still the sheer level
of depth and complexity just to them one
of these decisions is more than some
whole games have which is why Dex is one
of the finest immersive Sims of all time
and not just in how it creates its
gameplay but also in how that feeling of
complete Freedom extends to the story
letting you shape the world as you see
fit returning to the story regardless of
how you navigate the island you'll
eventually come across the leader of
this terrorist unit this is where the
game starts its descend into madness as
the leader says that they took the
Ambrosia not for themselves but for the
people further stating that the
government made the plague to control
the population he then goes on a tangent
and has some takes that some may
consider quite based you have a single
fact to back that up number one in 1945
corporations paid 50% of federal taxes
now they pay about
5% number two in 1900 90% of Americans
were self-employed now it's about 2% so
it's called consolidation strengthen
government and corporations weaken
individuals with taxes this can be done
imperceptibly over time the entire
executive branch is handpicked 19 of the
last 23 US presidents have been members
of the trilateral commission the
trilateral commission is financed by the
rockefellas and the Rothchilds don't
tell me that's a think tank anyone can
become a member but not everyone does
that's why they call it the secret
government at the time the guy can be
seen as a nutcase and nothing more but
it is peculiar why he decided to say say
that to you he has no reason to explain
himself but it gives off the impression
that he wants you to know it's the dev
at ion storm trying to get you to
question what's around you under the
guys of normal conversation within the
conversation is a talk about the
Ambrosia and where that shipment went
which is where the next mission takes us
I must say though nothing gets the few
neurons left in my brain to fizzle
together than some clever word play
Ambrosia is the name of the vaccine
which is a word with Origins from Greek
mythology used as a name for a specific
food or drink that gives longetivity or
immortality to those that consume it and
a vaccine being named as such is quite
fitting the game also does this with its
four AI datalis Icarus Helios and
Morpheus like Ambrosia they all come
from Greek mythology datalis and Icarus
were Father and Son respectively which
connects the fact that datalis is the
older AI with Icarus being the newer one
they will eventually come together
emerge into another AI called Helios who
is the personification of the sun
something that is uniquely tied to
datalis and Icarus as it's well known in
the myth that Icarus flew too close to
the Sun and burned up this is also not
the only time this she will use this
this specific character as the reboot
games protagonist Adam Jensen is seen as
Icarus in one of the game scenes
Morpheus on the other hand was made to
repeat people's life stories thanks to
being created by the Illuminati who
without a shadow of a doubt have lots of
people's data and information Morpheus
in the myth is the god of dreams and
appears in people's dreams for various
reasons the connection is that they both
know a lot about people without their
knowledge to add to this The Game's name
is a clever word play in itself the
original title was either going to be
shooter or troubleshooter which was
supposed to be ironic as the game was
not a SHO
even though it was eventually changed to
DSX which is a much better title might I
add DSX is an abbreviation of DSX
Machina a story Trope or a seemingly
unsolvable problem is resolved by an
unlikely scenario while not explicitly
stated it's possible that this DX Macha
was meant to be about the player video
games are fiction just pretend the best
games remove the disconnect as much as
possible by attempting to immerse the
player in the game world but all games
are fictional regardless of how good
they are at hiding it in most stories we
as the protagonist are also the ones to
do the impossible and through not just
the narrative structure but also outside
elements like Wiki guides and safe
scumming the player can get exactly what
they want one that always stuck with me
was the suicide mission of Mass Effect 2
a complicated final mission that could
see some of your crew you've come to
know and love di due to your negligence
some people and I'm guilty of this too
cannot stomach the fact that they pissed
off or killed the character they like so
rather than taking out on the chin and
moving on they'll reload a save and do
it again DSX is like all of these games
with the player being the DSX Machina
it's just more self-aware about it JC
while important character is really just
a small Cog and a much larger mechanism
but over the course of the game he'll be
able to stop the machine entirely he is
the cause of the people's Fates in the
side quest like Smuggler Ford and Sandra
and he is the force that propels the
narrative forward as a first mission
though Dex is off to a great start
mechanically lots of its story and
gameplay choices won't start to show
their hand for a little while longer but
since this is little more than a
glorified tutorial I think it gives the
player a good indication of how the game
is
played the first bunch of missions or
what I call act one is where things are
Ted
we're just regular old JC Den playing
the role of a unaco agent nothing out of
the ordinary it's not until the end of
Mission 3 where the story starts to
change but throughout these levels or
data pads and newspapers they give the
player a look outside the world of these
levels and it's clear to tell that it's
always been quite the [__] show there
was a recent outbreak in Brooklyn but
the National Guard had failed to contain
the virus and save those affected by it
furthermore the US Supreme Court had
passed a law a few years ago called grid
zoning which walls off Manhattan and its
other Burrows due to a bombing that
occurred there the issue is that these
place are completely walled off and foot
traffic between places is prohibited
they've essentially sectioned off parts
of New York from everyone else once
Supreme Court Justice backed up his
argument by saying that the freedom of
the American individual must be balanced
against the needs of a community to feel
safe and secure many have opposed this
law though and claimed that it is the
legalization of social oppression in a
more satirical twist we have another
news report about current president me
who's being criticized by Congress for
get this paying the money they owe to
the United Nations the cabinet has
routinely refused to pay what it owes
and is disappointed at president me for
doing such a thing one such Congressman
says quote no sir a superpower does not
pay rent in response it seems like
members of Congress have started
creating smear campaigns against him as
one person claimed that the crater on
Mars resembled the face of President me
proving that he is an extraterrestrial
alien this also connects to another
ongoing theory that the gray death is a
virus created by a group of aliens who
want to conquer us implying that
President me is one of these aliens
realistically anyone with a brain would
see how stupid this is but it's meant as
an element of satire by showing the
dumbest possible example of a kind of
thing that already exists in our world
today former president Barack Obama came
under Fire after being elected because
someone claimed that he wasn't a
natural-born US citizen to be president
in the US you must be born in the United
States live here for at least 14 years
and be older than 35 many people due to
his policies although more likely for
racist reasons thought that Barack Obama
was not eligible to be president
claiming that he was born in Kenya this
led to him showing the American people
his birth certificate but even when
faced with the facts people continue to
deny it people do not like to admit that
they're wrong as humans we like to win
and to be correct so being wrong is the
same as losing or admitting defeat but
the most capable of people can learn
from those failures and apply that to
their future endeavors for most people
falling to misinformation results in
them doubling down on their claim or
just shutting their ears to the
conversation entirely that's why
conspiracy theories such as these can
have drastic consequences for them most
people likely believe that Obama was
born in Hawaii just as the certificate
said but there are still quite a few
people out there who can't accept they
might be wrong so they continue to push
the idea whenever they can
misinformation can be harmful not just
because of what it can do to a person's
life but also by way of distracting
people from the topic at hand president
me might actually be a bad president but
diverting the conversation away from his
actual policies to focus on some bogus
claim that he is an alien is absurd yet
it probably worked because people who
hate him don't care about the facts and
we use that info as ammo even if it's a
complete dud this newspaper was also
what prompted me to mention that comment
about Kojima and MGs too I wouldn't say
neither Spectre nor Kojima predicted the
future as these issues they tackle were
relevant or at least showing their faces
back then too but it is still quite
impressive that a piece of media from
over two decades ago could still be
brought up in conversation today thex
for the most part is a drastic look at
our world yeah we don't have people
claiming that presidents are aliens but
the core concept of smear campaigns and
illegitimate claims are still something
that happens today cuz people can't get
along another group of people who
apparently can't get along is Paul and
unatco as mission three has a sneaking
into an an SE control military base to
find that Ambrosia were trying to secure
in the first mission before running into
our brother Paul right in the core of
the base he immediately admits that he's
been working with NSF the whole time and
that yako is the enemy and not them
while he doesn't show up much in the
game and could die due to your actions
in a future Mission thus making his
screen time even less which is something
I'm not a huge fan of it was smart to
make Paul the one to relay this info to
JC this conversation is similar to the
one we had with the terrorist leader
from the first mission but given the
context of that mission and the fact
that it was only 30 minutes into the
game You' be forgiven for thinking he
was nothing more than a Mindless quack
but Paul is different he's the brother
of JC he has no reason to lie to you so
even though you might not agree with
what he has to say it's at least worth
hearing him out according to him the
virus is indeed man-made and the UN
cannot be trusted he urges us to talk to
the leader lebedev if we want to know
more he doesn't say much originally
because we're interrupted by Anna but
given that Paul betrayed Uno and joined
him letting him speak would be able to
give us a better understanding of what's
going on here assuming you do he
elaborates on his prior claims and
states that both Paul and J were
experimental humans made by Majestic 12
mj12 wanted to have their own Super
Soldier as a sort of Ace in the Hole and
Paul was originally designed to be that
Soldier until they started becoming
displeased with his actions and then
decided to take JC out of the tank the
key difference between the brothers is
that JC was raised out his parents
involvement JC's whole life was meant to
be a soldier who has unwavering loyalty
to Uno and mj12 the concept of Free Will
and the ability to make our own choices
even if they're bad ones is the one
thing that defines a human being taking
that away from someone makes them less
like a human more like a pawn and this
is further exacerbated by what follows
as JC reports back to unco for a
briefing only hear that they've
activated Paul's kill switch Paul was
nothing more than a tool for this group
to use to their liking and once he was
no longer useful they tossed him in the
trash fortunately we will find out that
Paul is still alive but it creates this
odd feeling of discomfort in the player
and JC that just like Paul they are
tools nothing more JC's newest mission
is to find Tracer Tong a contact of
Paul's in Hong Kong and kill him we
aren't going to do that though and inste
visit Paul his apartment in Hell's
Kitchen to see how he's doing this is
where the next layer of the rabbit hole
starts to form as Paul wants us to relay
a signal to his NSF allies but upon
doing that Walter immediately instructs
all yako Troopers to attack us from here
on out yako and some of the local police
will be on our ass shooting us without
question manderly is the leader of unaco
but he's more of a pretty face for the
company as Walter takes over shortly
after and starts using the power of FEMA
to enact martial law unaco will soon
flood the streets of Hell's Kitchen and
issue a curfew in not that no one can go
out he'll also shut down some New York
canals and shipyards that he can escort
a freighter carrying tons of the gr
death virus to the ports without being
caught it's clear that his power knows
no bounds and is someone who is without
question a threat to the world however
through Walter DSX keeps continuity with
an ongoing conspiracy related to FEMA
FEMA or the Federal Emergency Management
agency is a group of people who help out
during natural disasters if something
like a hurricane were to hit a state or
country FEMA would usually be the first
ones to arrive and offer Aid and
assistance some people believe that FEMA
uses these opportunities to get rid of
individuals targeted by the new world
order under the guys that they're
enacting martial law in all fairness the
claims do have some way to them as a
real program called Rex 84 does just
that its instructions detailed how the
US government would be able to detain
residents it deems as National Security
threats if the president declares a
National Emergency these people would
then be detained at concentration camps
operated and run by FEMA now while that
may not sound bizarre as people who are
National threats to the country should
be detained consider the fact that
following the bombing of Pearl Harbor
tens of thousands of Japanese American
citizens were removed from their homes
and forced to live in camps during World
War II simply because the government
thought that anyone who was Japanese
could be a threat to the US relating
this to DSX Rex 84 called rx84 in-game
was a directive that Walter and Bob Page
did end up enacting towards the later
half of the game except it ended up
failing due to multiple governments and
military officials refusing to comply
with Walter and FEMA's orders still the
fact that they even have this power to
begin with is terrifying and shows that
FEMA and Majestic 12 will stop at
nothing until the world is eating out of
the palm of their hands the only person
who becomes quite the thorn in their
side and has the chance to disrupt this
operation is JC which is why Walter
sends you Neco troops after him this
upcoming section is where the intended
death sequence comes in as you're meant
to die either here or make it to the
subway only for you to be stopped by
Gunther who arrest you on site this then
places you in a jail cell deep in a
Majestic 12 lab several floors below our
place of employment further confirming
that mj12 is always just a few meters
away from us helping us Escape though is
datalist an AI who used to be allied
with m J12 but is now working for JC
after learning of his defection from
unatco while datal list can help JC
Escape he has another problem Walter
activated his kill switch and now he has
23 hours left until it goes off shutting
off his augmentations and killing him
for good to solve this conundrum we have
to go to Hong Kong and meet with Tracer
Tong the one who worked for Paul to see
if we can get this removed Hong Kong is
a gorgeous place as the market is packed
to the brim with people and stalls of
all kinds we also haven't talked about
this much but the music throughout this
game is fantastic I tend to use the osts
of the games I'm talking about to keep
things consistent and most games have
anywhere between 60 to 90 minutes of
music to listen to DSX has a whopping 5
hours of different soundtracks because
there is a different Ambience
conversation battle and death track for
every level and this goes for Anytime
there is a new location too right before
Hong Kong We're stopped at a helipad
anyy to unlock the restrictions put on
the helicopters that we can escape this
is like a 10-minute section at most that
you will only ever visit one time yet it
has has a unique track specific to this
location the rest of the soundtrack
though does continue to go the extra
mile and uplifting the life of its
respective levels some of which you may
have already heard throughout the video
like the corporate and peaceful tune of
unatco or the lonely but surprisingly
comforting feeling of exploring the
duclair
[Music]
Chateau all of it is fantastic and is
without a doubt the best collection of
Music in the entire series just because
we're in a different country though
doesn't mean our continued themes of
corruption and conspiracy are suddenly
going to disappear Hong Kong has been in
the midst of a war between the red arrow
and the Luminous path Triad gangs and at
the heart of this conflict is a blue
dragon sword the Dragon Sword was made
by Majestic 12 in one of their
experiments but the leader of the red
arrow stole the original prototype this
would have given the game more power
over luminous path so woman named Maggie
Chow killed the red arrow leader Blended
on the Luminous path so the two would
start a clan war Maggie Chow also Happ
to work for Majestic 12 so this whole
plan was made as an act by Majestic 12
to keep its power over Hong Kong so to
stop the fighting we're going to get the
sword back make a few copies and then
give them to each of the tri gain they
could stop fighting as corny of a plot
as this sounds seeing as this could very
easily serve as the main plot for a rush
hour sequel the reason we're doing this
is because the Luminous path is holding
Tracer Tong in their base so we scratch
their back and they scratch ours getting
the groups to consider a truce is all we
have to do to enter But actually getting
them to follow through on that truce is
what will happen next the end of this
quest line has us visiting the labs of
versal Life a business owned by Majestic
12 once we make it down here datalist
instructs us how to destroy the group's
Universal conductor which is the device
the group used to manufacture the gray
death Tracer Tong then points out that
from the information we gathered they're
planning on shipping some more gray
death to New York via a freighter but
that freighter used to be owned by
Stanton Dow a member of the Illuminati
like all good stories a steady growth of
escalation is necessary to make the
story flow well and since DSX is a game
about conspiracy theories it's only
natural that the apex of the game's
escalation is a meeting with the the
most popular conspiracy theory to date
the Final Act of the game is where
things really start to go back to its
older Roots as most of these missions
are like the first mission infiltrating
a large base for the entirety of the
runtime first we start with the aention
frighter then we have to move through
the streets of Paris and even take a
quick trip to the long confusing Halls
of the country's catacombs along the way
we start to learn a bit more about Bob
pagee as he seems to be the head of
Majestic 12 but anything we know about
him is just anything the public knows
well Bob pagee used to be a part of the
Illuminati but eventually broke off to
form Majestic 12 around 20 30 a couple
decades before the game took place the
US government was about to collapse
rather than help them the Illuminati
opted to watch them crumble so they
could then take the position of power
for themselves however the US did not
collapse which caused problems for the
organization annoyed by its current
direction Bob Page then work with
Majestic 12 who at the time was just a
small subsection of the Illuminati to
overthrow them which is why the
Illuminati was forced to go into hiding
and why Bob pagee has more power under
Majestic 12 so instead of enemies to
lovers we have lovers to enemies what's
even worse is that Bob Page also created
What's called the aquinus protocol a
project that was basically going to be a
better internet but in reality it was a
tool used by Majestic 12 to have
complete control over the Internet this
is of course on top of the fact that he
is currently manufacturing a widespread
play to control manipulate the
population fortunately we do have a way
to stop him but that requires us to meet
another member of the Illuminati Morgan
Everett is his name who instructs us to
go to replace in vanderberg as the laer
also has a universal conductor that we
can use to synthesize a cure for the
virus all of this culminates in the
final peak of the story and just like
the Illuminati a game of conspiracies
would not be complete if we didn't take
a trip to Area 51 while exploring at St
callways you'll be met with a call by
your allies who all want you to enact
their plan for the base which in turn
provides an ending to the game Tracer
Tong wants us to destroy Area 51 doing
so would kill Bob pagee along with the
aquinus protocol which Tracer Tong finds
to be too dangerous for anyone to own
the drawback is that destroying this
would send the world into a dark age as
it's essentially like removing the
internet for good all forms of
entertainment and communication would be
gone and companies would not only have
slower production rates but people who
rely on technology for their jobs would
be screwed it's an awful outcome but one
that he considers to be a necessary evil
Morgan Everett on the other hand wants
to keep the base and he believes that we
could use the aquinus protocol and
Helios to our advantage as he also
extends JC an invitation to join the
Illuminati while the world in theory
would go back to normal and not have the
Doomsday Clock ringing anymore it would
be once again ruled by a shadow
organization whose first and foremost
goal is to make sure they remain on top
yeah they might be a benefit to society
something we will see in the sequel's
endings but if something gets in their
way or threatens their rule consider
that a thing of the past which is both
harmful and restricts the personal
freedoms the people of the world should
have continuing the theme of personal
freedom Helios wants to merge with JC to
create the perfect ruler Helios believes
themselves to be the perfect ruler
because they are a machine and thus lack
the human desire of ambition Helios does
not seek power to get something out of
it like the previous two he has no way
to feel ambition so he rules because he
can
it also believes that the checks and
balances system Democratic societies
often create aren't capable anymore as
human beings aren't able to govern
people checks imbalances keeps the
branches of the governments in check so
that no branch is stronger or better
than the other so the government
branches govern themselves because
everyone needs to be kept in check with
each other Helios thinks that this is
because people who run branches are
humans and not a machine like them this
however would turn the world into a
dictatorship and can an AI be trusted to
do that even with JC involved in the
process Helios was designed to for
Humanity but what differentiates between
enhancing and not enhancing Humanity
would it take unnecessary or hostile
steps in order to achieve this goal like
killing certain people under the guys
that it's for the greater good while all
of these endings are great realistically
are any of these endings good morally
speaking not at all and this might be
one of my favorite moments in the game
as it acts as a sort of unveiling of the
cloth to show that this was all just a
simulation and that we like JC are only
as powerful as the script wants us to be
JC is the DSX Macha that can solve the
unsolvable so by that metric the player
two is the DSX Machina but we can only
solve the unsolvable thanks the devs
allowing us to do so in the same way
yako is having its strings pulled by
Majestic 12 the player's having its
strings pulled by the devs letting them
play Hero for as long as they want
before revealing that they won't get the
ending they wanted there is no Golden
Goose of an ending here something has to
give we can beat anything the game
throws at us except fate itself and that
fate is about to be decided right now
well enroy the mor complexities of each
ending the main issue with them is that
they're all surface level looks at what
occurred take the Helios ending choosing
to merge sees JC walk into the chamber
merge with Helios and that's it no extra
cut scene showing the Future No
showcasing of the endings ramifications
nope just nothing the same applies to
Tracer Tong which has JC blowing up the
base before the game cuts to Black this
one I was most disappointed in as they
could have shown how the world was
impacted by the destruction of the net
or if it even had been affected at all
because as it stands we like the world
are left in the dark as to what happened
each ending does come with a quote which
is a nice touch but it mainly just
reinforces what the endings are about
the Helios path ends with a quote from
philosopher voler that says if there
were no God it'd be necessary to invent
him referring to how humans for as much
as we like to have free will find
comfort in being ordered around by a
higher power such as God God in all
religions instructs those who believe in
the faith on how to live that's why
Christians give up meat for Lent or why
Muslims spray multiple times a day these
rules keep people in line but it's to
serve a higher power someone that in
turn will grant them guidance and
happiness in this life and after this JC
Helios combo would be the invented god
of the new world they would be the
ultimate rulers of the world and while
that's a solid start we don't know much
about JC's attitude as much of it as
shaped by the player and the same goes
for
Helios still the vibe of the endings if
we can call it that is still strong the
moral conundrums of not being able to
discern what is best for the world are
the kind of endings I enjoy I always end
up pausing the game during times like
this and talking about these endings out
allowed to myself in order to come to a
proper conclusion which was only
possible because I was narratively
invested in what the game was about it
put me in the shoes of JC Denton and I
felt like I needed to make the best
choice here feeling this way does not
come from every game a bad game wouldn't
bother with this and most of your
discussion about the ending would be
less about which one is the best for the
world and more like which one is the
fastest way to the end credits DSX is
truly a master class of Storytelling and
for this kind of thing to exist in the
year 2000 is almost unheard of it's a
Timeless classic and easily one of the
most important games of all time and
most of the public agreed too while the
game didn't exactly sell well even by
2000 standards only achieving 1 million
sales in 2009 9 years after release the
critical reception was largely positive
with scores rarely hitting a low of
eight While most gave it nines and 10
what's more important though is that
Warr inspectre was able to make his
dream game and what a dream of a game it
was it's only natural though that a
sequel would follow but how do you make
a sequel to one of the most impressive
games of all
time unfor fortunately I don't have an
answer for that but I can say with
absolute certainty that Invisible War is
not the correct one while initial sales
and reviews were met with positivity
many people in retrospect including
Warren Spectre himself see Invisible War
as the weakest entry in the series the
game is the antithesis of everything
that made the first game great there
were some Valiant attempts to replicate
the beauty of the original but a lot of
it fails to meet that standard most of
this comes from the oversimplification
of the old systems there are no longer
different calibers of ammo and various
types of ammo within the same caliber as
all ammo within the guns is universal
logins passwords or key codes no longer
need to be typed out and instead are
just able to be opened if you have the
respective code health is no longer
split between your limbs but is now just
a singular health bar skills and
augments are now just morphed into
augments and multi-tools ironically
enough actually live up to their name
and are a multi-purpose tool keeping
their original purpose but also gaining
the ability to unlock things you would
otherwise need a lockpick for as much as
it sounds like I'm complaining about
this though I don't really mind it
mostly DSX was is quite rough around the
edges and Invisible War does attempt to
smooth out those edges but ends up going
too far the gameplay isn't bad enough
for me to dislike it but I'm also not
dropping to my knees and screaming how
could something this genius possibly be
created by a mere human it's okay it
functions and that's about it and this
extends to most of the game including
its story it does things that's for sure
but I have no strong feelings about it
either way what a real [__] position
that is for me to be in a good game is
fun to talk about cuz you get to gush
about his Beauty and impressive quality
and if it's a bad game I can lament
about its systems offer constructive
criticism or just simply share something
that didn't quite work out the way it
was intended I struggled to do either of
that with Invisible War as it's right in
the middle not bad not good but boring
most of my play time was just spent idly
playing not really engaging with the
content in front of me because of its
utter failure to keep me interested the
world of Invisible War feels as lifeless
as the game itself what made DSX shine
was its attention to detail NPCs were
walking and talking with each other and
some may have even gotten threatened
like this boy in Hong Kong who you could
follow for a solid 10 minutes and within
that time berates this woman reports
back to the Luminous path goes back
expecting money reports his success to
the guard and then goes back to the
kiosk to do what he was told to do all
of that happens independently of the
player and can be missed if they don't
pay attention almost all the NPCs in
this game sit in the same area and never
move around they are lifeless bodies
that only exist so that the player has
someone to talk to rather than feeling
like an actual person in the world one
of its biggest failings though is
actually one of its biggest Innovations
the factions Invisible War gives the
player the ability to join up with
various factions and now occupy the land
for context Invisible War takes place 20
years after the first game and due to
what was called the collapse the world
has been sort of splintered leaving
newer groups the opportunity to pop up
and reap the benefits this also sounds
like the Dark Age ending implying that
that option was Canon but it's not that
simple and I'll explain why later but
these new groups consist of the World
Trade Organization or the WTO the order
and the Omar the WTO is a very basic
basic military faction that has gone
head-to-head with the order a religious
fanatical Cult of sorts that despises
augmented people and want to purge the
world of all biomodification once you
leave the tutorial area you can choose
which objectives you want to accomplish
if your values align more with the WTO
and their love for capitalism and
commerce then you can join them but if
you want to join the order even though
you yourself are a biomodified human
then you could be their Lackey too the
issue is that all the decisions you make
won't matter anyway the game is nice
enough to label each objective by who
gave it to you but more often than not
you can do both since each group has
different goals here in Cairo the order
wants me to find out a cure for the
plague polluting the city while the WTO
wants you to destroy a greenhouse well
this could provide a morally interesting
choice the player can just do both with
very little consequence this is also
further compounded by the fact that
Cairo is the only location you come back
to unlike the previous games where your
actions could evolve and change allowing
you to see the consequences of your
actions many of the decisions are never
seen due to the game's insistence on
giving you new locations to explore
rather than the old ones in all fairness
not every decision is like this
sometimes the choices you make can be
heard about at a new station which is
about the laziest way you could do it
but at least they consider the fact that
players might be curious to hear about
what happened as a result of their
choice there were also a few missions
where the two groups ideals do intersect
like when you have to choose between
sparing or killing a specific NPC where
this drops the ball though is the lack
of consequence minus one moment most of
these missions result in the opposing
side angerly calling you disappointed
that you would side with the Enemy it's
like the equivalent of Internet bullying
all bark no bite that one moment though
did admittedly catch me by surprise but
even that was met with dissatisfaction I
had decided in Egypt to do the WTO
missions first and then the orders well
the second in command of the order
didn't like that I did the WTO missions
so she called me letting me know that I
betrayed the organization and that a hit
squad was on their way to kill me which
is exactly what happens however Not only
was this the only time this ever
happened among all the factions but the
second in command called me after I
dealt with them and basically said you
survived this but I hope you learn that
we are not to be messed with and you'll
follow our orders next time
you just sent armed thugs to take me out
I feel like we passed a point of no
return regarding our friendship like
five steps ago this is also of course
not even mentioning the fact that both
of these factions specifically work for
the same group both the leaders of the
WTO and the order are members of the
Illuminati they did this so that people
could have healthy competition the WTO
is a capitalistic and commercialized
group of people while the order
completely opposes those exact ideals
among of course the more Sinister belief
that they don't like biom modifications
the plan was eventually to unite the
world through these groups and bring
them under one secular society which
would create their new world order part
of me understands why this is here
because the game wants to make the
player feel disappointed and worthless
that all their decisions were pointless
because all they were essentially doing
was stoking the fires between each group
which only served to go the Illuminati
more like how there's two dozen
different chocolate brands under the
same name so no matter which one you buy
The House Always Wins but this doesn't
work here as everything is meaningless
this whole mechanic was designed to give
the player the freedom to choose which
faction they want to support but it
doesn't go anywhere since there was
never any choice to begin with the
causes and effects were all fabricated a
lie Spa By the Illuminati and the game
hoping that you'd be stupid enough to
engage with the series best idea that
has had so far the game even does this
again with a coffee company that's more
akin to the example I just used where
two companies named pquad and qu quid
are at odds at one another and you're
able to assist one of the companies by
completing a job for them only to find
out that both companies are owned by the
same brand so the Rivalry was made just
to stoke the fires and push sales Al
while the actual owners of the business
business are worried about losing their
jobs all this is is an attempt by the
game to lure you in only to pull the rug
out from under you the game is all about
rug pulling constantly ripping it out
from under you with every choice and
decision you make until you decide that
enough is enough and you rip it up
yourself in a game design context that
is problematic as you start to look at
the missions from a mechanical
perspective and not a narrative one yeah
I could kill the Headmaster of a school
who plans to kill all these children
because he's secret working for the
Templars and they hate biomodified
people or I could report it to the
police police and get a citizen bonus
and then hope they follow up on their
job I could also enroll a girl into that
school even though that would basically
be the equivalent of signing her death
sentence but her mother's paying me and
I like money it's the exact same problem
we talked about in the previous section
being narratively invested in the
fiction has you taking simple requests
like this with extreme care and
consideration but doing so means you're
already more invested in the game than
it is in
itself to top this all off we have the
third group that I've been neglecting to
talk about the Omar and they might be
the most disappointing of them all due
to their underutilization in the plot as
a whole the Omar are a group of over
modified beings who only care about
being the strongest and using the
top-of-line modifications even the ones
that are illegal they also modified
their prefrontal loes to the cortical
interface that all the Omar are under
one Collective hive mind it's highly
disturbing and even though the visuals
aren't doing them any justice the idea
that they are more machined than man is
easy enough to understand they are
opposites to some of the factions in
this game as those groups would prefer
the world to be organic and normal while
the Omar see themselves is the next
evolutionary step for Humanity all of
that is fantastic and they are still by
many metrics my favorite faction in the
game but that's just what they are in
the lore in game they're little more
than Black Market dealers all the Omar
do in the game is sit in a secluded area
of the map and sell you items they might
even give you a discount if you perform
a service for them but none of the
services have anything to do with the
other factions or the plot at large as
most having you kill specific people and
then finding their enhanced biom
modifications that you can scan them and
give them to the Omar it's the worst
possible way to drop the ball as the
most interesting faction in this whole
game are just Merchants the factions of
Invisible War are its most ambitious and
worst mechanic in the game giving the
player the option to choose who they
want to side with is such a great idea
as it further expands the play how you
want plan that Warren Spectre wanted for
the series but the factions themselves
are lifeless Hollow not likable and
rarely important which is a problem as
their never-ending conflicts are the
central plot of the game Invisible War
may have a major major focus on factions
but it also has a major focus on its
protagonist Alex D said 20 years in the
future Alex was sent to a place called
Tarsus Academy to be trained for
Humanity's future the trainees here
would undergo many exams and tests to be
selected for a variety of jobs ranging
from world leaders to security guards
originally he was stationed in Chicago
until terrorists came by and blew up the
whole facility along most of the city
forc them to go to their branch in
Seattle joining Alex is three other
trainees claraa Billy and Leo it's
eventually discovered though that this
Tarsus Academy is just a front for a
group called apostal core who made the
company to experiment on the trainees
that's because apostal core is run by JC
Denton this group wasn't mentioned in
the ending though which begs the
question of what ending was actually
chosen well the answer is all of
them so firstly the how well despite
each of these endings requiring
different steps and ending in multiple
different ways canonically JC merged
with Helios killed Bob Page blew up Bara
51 causing the aquinus network to go
dark and then tried to join the Illumina
naughty except the merging caused severe
damage to JC forcing to be put into
suspended animation for the time being
as for the why well they don't actually
know all we have is a comment from one
of the devs who just thought that all
the endings at once would be better than
just one usually three heads are better
than one but three is also a crowd still
I don't mind the decision mainly because
it kept the one thing I cared about
which was the Dark Age of the internet
and that is what gave birth to the
collapse a period where all over the
world countries were at War and the
world was plunged into an economic
recession it's the start of a very
interesting post-apocalypse / dystopian
setting too bad most of the levels we
explore look fine and unted or sometimes
even better off than you would expect
which doesn't exactly connect well to
the ending but the idea is there JC is
doing all this with a posal core though
because they need some with his DNA and
that's why the trainees including Alex
were undergoing so many tests oddly
enough Alex Denton was teased back in
the first game in Area 51 there are
tankers filled with clones one of which
is named Alex Denton back then it was a
scary reminder that JC is nothing more
than a tool and could have been easily
replaced just like how we replace Paul
by taking on his missions and using his
contacts but now it's used as a method
of foreshadowing but apostal core should
have probably left him in the tank for a
bit longer or at least taught him some
basic communication skills because he
approaches every conversation without
even a hint of Personality he is quite
possibly the blandest character I've
ever listened to hi what's going on it
looks like this facility is under attack
I appreciate that listen I'm serious you
didn't hear the explosions I saw a guard
killed right in front of me in the
apartment level the traines we are a bit
better but their quality does vary
depending on who we talk about each of
the trainees have their own Journeys
that they go on throughout the game and
is the one thing that the player can see
evolve in real time due to their
decisions the three of them all go to
different organizations after realizing
Tarsus and apostal Corp were just using
them Billy goes to the order clar to the
WTO and Leo to the Omar Clara's story
isn't exactly interesting but it is
realistic as she wanted to join the WTO
to uphold their values she'll join you
on a couple missions then tell you about
how well she's doing at the WTO and even
though she does learned that it's really
the Illuminati pulling the strings she
says that she still believes in the WTO
just not its leader which is a bit of a
naive way of looking at things but I
kind of get it it eventually ends with
her being kidnapped by the WTO forcing
us to comply with what the Illuminati
wants us to do or have her die as a
consequence you can however rescue her
yourself before that happens which is a
nice touch and she'll be grateful saying
that she's going to quit the
organization and live a normal life back
in Seattle further remarking that all
this training she did was about killing
people and she doesn't want to do that
anymore so the most Riv Arc for a
character to take but it makes sense and
I respect it Leo's Arc is the opposite
and was quite interesting to see unfold
Leo starts off as this cocky [__]
that's full of himself but after
learning of Tarsus he goes solo for a
while and picks up some odd security
jobs here and there until he's recruited
by the Omar most of his journey has
spent doing just that being security for
the Omar dealers until later when we see
they gave him one of their suits which
is the phase one of their transformation
he's eventually going to be selected for
phase two which is when he'll receive
that interface and be put in the hive
mine but he's getting cold feet going
all the way this however upsets the Omar
who would tell him that they would do it
by force if he didn't comply but we can
help him Escape if we have enough money
which leads to him leaving the
organization it's a nice parallel to his
time at Tarsus as he's being used as a
tool for someone else's gain again his
final moment is actually a part of an
ending which we'll talk about later but
going down this route would be able to
give him the ability to choose how to
live his life and do what he wants to do
for the first time which is a really
great end to his story Billy on the
other hand bothers me greatly Billy is
the main character among the trainees as
she has seen in the opening cut scene
and is the only friend of Alex's Pride
entering the Tarsus Academy that's why
her eventual betrayal to Ally with the
knight's Templar hurts even more as she
was a close friend pretty much all of it
is fine honestly my only real complaint
is the group she's joining she
eventually starts with the order before
moving to the Templars who are like a
more fanatical version of them yet Billy
is a biomodified agent so she's working
for an organization hellbent on
eliminating people like her which
strikes me as weird Billy also doesn't
show up for most of the games so it's
hard to tell what actually swayed her
opinion on this if there was maybe a
moment where she renounces her
augmentations saying that she had these
put onto her by force and believes
they've actively made her life worse
which is why the world should be purg of
them then that's a perfectly normal
reason to join the Templars but she
doesn't explain why she just agrees with
their ideals not really confronting the
fact that she is among the people they
hate still the trainees are a nice
addition to the game as they're similar
in structure to Sandra from the first
game a person who meet across the game
whose life will be impacted by your
decisions for good or ill and those are
the kind of stories I enjoy most in this
series
like the first game the initial Act is
the tamest part of the story but it's
also ironically the most confusing due
to the missions being split across the
factions I was initially confused as to
where the story was even going each
group just had you doing different
objectives that conveniently take place
in the same locations and it took a
while for me to understand where all
this was leading to which is right when
I was told that they were two sides of
the same coin while the locations
themselves are noticeable downgrade from
the previous games it does at least keep
some of the personality of the first
game by giving the player multiple
options to approach a given objective
and for most of the levels to have tons
of secondary objectives to do in them
now as I said most of these objectives
aren't narratively important and should
only be done for the gameplay benefits
they could provide but I am glad that
they at least Carri that over from the
prior game where the end of this act
begins is towards the end of Cairo as
while the two groups do have their
differences they both want Alex to find
out more information on apostal core
which makes sense given that they're
both under the same faction the
Illuminati apostel core and the Knights
Templar are the three main factions of
the game who will ask Alex for help in
furthering their goals all the way to
the end where they provide you with an
ending to the game itself just like the
WTO in the order they also have their
own conflicts of interest regarding
certain topics which force you to choose
who to go with unfortunately that too
doesn't matter a hypothetical point of
no return doesn't exist in Invisible War
right until you push the final button
that officially locks in your ending
until then you can do as many different
objectives as you want or outright work
against a specific faction by constantly
foiling their plans only for them to
still let you join them and take on
their ending I can understand wanting
the player to see all the content but
locking the the player out of content
would be a perfect excuse for another
playthrough not that I want to do
another playthrough of Invisible War but
it would be a reason to do one if I
wanted to where the story starts to take
a turn is just after learning about the
Illuminati scheme to use the two groups
against each other as after this we go
through a portal to Antarctica which is
where JC is currently being held thanks
to him being in control of Area 51 at
the time he was also able to avoy the
help of the aliens located here well
this is already a very wild piece of
lore to include in the game I'm honestly
not a huge fan of how the game handles
aliens and it reminds me of lot of what
Fallout 3 did to aliens in that Series
in the original Fallout aliens were a
secret event that you could come across
it was meant as dumb fun though as it
played into the 1950s era Fallout when
Bethesda acquired the rights of the game
they ended up evolving the aliens into
more than just a joke by making them a
canical part of the world and then made
the player spend an entire DLC on board
one of the ships it was so very clearly
a joke but they went way too far with
the bit which makes the whole situation
rather funny since it is easily the
worst DLC of that game in DSX area 51
and Versa life bolt had aliens both of
which were owned by Majestic 12 them
experimenting on Aliens just showed how
much power and Technology they had and
it also played into the real Majestic 12
except in both games it's clarified that
the aliens aren't really aliens but
people who are genetically modified they
aren't really aliens they just happen to
look like a traditional alien somehow
this isn't really invisible War's fault
though as it's the first game that did
start this but Invisible War allows you
to talk and interact with them and I
feel like both games inclusions take
away their alien isness and it never sat
right with me once we make it to the
core of the base we come across JC
Denton for the first time who tells us a
bit about his plan for the world while
the first part of the game is all about
setting up the Illuminati and confusing
you the whole way through the second
part is all about the factions telling
you their plans which will be important
as you will ultimately have to choose
who decide with in a nice thematic twist
the game ends where the series begins at
Liberty Island each of the three groups
have dug themselves into a section of
the island while carefully planning ways
to kill off the others now once again
the game isn't really showcasing that
quite well as the groups are so far
apart from each other that they rarely
interact at all but that's more on
account of the engine itself and not the
game's design you're also given allies
in this level taking the form of whoever
you chose to side with in the previous
Mission which ultimately serves to make
this whole ending extremely disjointed
as you go into this Mission with allies
that you can then betray right at the
end the first group you'll come across
is JC and possibly Paul depending on
your actions in the previous Mission
their vision for the world has been to
make one fully connected Universe using
Helios unlike many civilizations that
see Humanity as chaotic something that
needs to be ruled over and controlled JC
and Helio see it is something to be
welcomed as long as the individuals are
equal on all fronts JC asks if it's fair
that one child be born into an
impoverished life with very little food
and money while one gets born into a
wealthy family and flush with more money
than most will ever see these
differences Splinter humanity and
ultimately cause more problems but
according to JC if everyone was enhanced
to a Level Playing Field then the world
could improve this ending essentially
ends up creating a perfected version of
democracy Helios has all the power to
handle all the branches of government at
once if everyone is connected to Helios
major judicial decisions can be done on
a daily if not more frequent basis I got
to be honest I didn't exactly expect
this level of complexity from an
invisible War as it not only fleshes out
the idea Helios had in the first game
but it also oddly enough corrects
current criticisms of democracy to make
the ending seem more compelling for as
great as Democratic Society can be it's
not without its faults a democratic
government usually has a system for how
it handles things which causes things to
get backed up and take longer than they
should in a recent study about this
topic it was discovered that most
Supreme Court cases on average take
about 586 days to be completed through
Helios this would be shrunken down to
less than a day another fault of the
system is the constant switching of
policies every election year since the
president can change as quick as once
every four years most of their early
legislations are the removal of laws and
bills created by their predecessor to
put it another way former president
Donald Trump has been very vocal about
his stance on immigration going as far
as to build a wall near the southern
border B and Biden was elected back in
2020 he immediately holds a production
on the wall assuming Trump gets
reelected next year I have no doubt that
this policy will once again return this
back and forth switching can be
problematic not just for the everyday
citizen who has to keep up with all this
but also for the country as the first
year for most president's terms is just
spent playing catchup and while JC
didn't explicitly say this I can assume
he and Helios to be the world's rulers
so their policies will never change and
the world can always be on the path of
progress The Only Fault of JC's plan is
actually not with democracy itself but
rather his version of it as this
connection with Helios would be a
complete invasion of privacy it's
important to point out that the people
would be connected not assimilated into
Helios as opposed to someone like the
Omar but being connected all the time
would be exhausting and wouldn't allow
for any kind of personal freedom it's
like the grid zoning law from the first
game the rights and freedoms of the
individual should be balanced around
their safety and is gaining a bit of
safety worth losing some to all of your
privacy the second group attempting to
stay claim in the world is once again
the Illuminati just like before they
want to rule the world from the Shadows
they want to know and handle all the
business transactions in the world while
also being on top at every possible step
they are by far the easiest to
understand is the only thing that's
actually changed is their management who
specifically are a nice call back to the
first game as their leaders are Chad
dummier and Nicollet declair Chad was
the leader of silhouette a French
militia group who opposed mj12 and
Nicollet was the daughter of Beth
duclair a former Illuminati member and
someone we met with previously under
their control the Illuminati would get
exactly what they want while also ruling
over the world via the use of an AI
called ofilia who station at a giant
spaceship circling the earth this would
also prevent the Illuminati from ever
being overtaken again like the incident
with Bob Page is now that exist outside
the confines of Earth this ending also
happens to be the more ambiguous of the
bunch as the game doesn't show what the
world is like for the common folk of the
world but the ending narration does seem
to imply that the world is growing
thriving and is safe the third group
asking for Alex's assistance is the
knight's Templar as I said before they
were a more fanatical version of the
order and that's because they originally
started from there well the group did
exist before the collapse the new post
collapse Templars were led by luminan
San a former member of the order who
felt that the order was drifting too far
away from its original ideals so rather
than fix it from the inside San decided
to create a whole new group San chose to
reignite the Templars because his ideals
fit neatly with that of the old Templars
during the Crusades the Templars back
then fought many wars with the Middle
East in attempt to reclaim the holy land
and stop Muslim expansion and the new
Templars under San want to continue this
but against biom modifications and the
push to install yourself with multiple
mechanical systems this is why 's
decision to Ally with them still bothers
me because she's working for people who
would see her as a stain on the earth
and I don't recall the game ever
mentioning why she joined in the first
place only that she did because of her
hatred for apostal core this is further
reinforced by their end slide which
shows a few bodies hanging from the
rafters while soman preaches to the
group about their sermons while the
group ultimately opposes the concept of
biomodification as their objective is to
use counter nanites to remove the mods
in people's body without hurting the
host it's clear that they don't mind a
bit of murder if it furthers their goal
do doing this would not only strengthen
their forces but it would also weaken
the Illuminati as they depend on these
upgrades for their own Ambitions giving
San and the Templars complete control
the world like before while some of the
endings may be more palatable than
others they all come with their own
baggage which is why Invisible War
allows you to enact a fourth ending
where you kill all the leaders of the
game JC Paul Chad nicholet and Simon and
let the world decide for itself all of
the leaders want to control the world to
fit their own ideals and needs this
ending would allow the people the common
folk to do it themselves to quote the
big boss himself it's not about changing
the world it's about doing our best to
leave the world the way it is this
however in a rather comedic way ends up
resulting in the worst ending possible
as for the next 200 years the world will
be caught up in constant Wars with a
strong rule the weak eventually giving
birth to a complete Mad Max style
post-apocalypse I initially found this
ending to be quite funny as it's
basically saying that leaving people to
their own devices would cause allout War
but it does pose a rather interesting
question about whether or not the world
should be ruled by a governing body as
let some kind of control the world could
be chaotic
that said you could argue that this
destruction was inevitable and that at
the very least the world delved into
chaos on its own terms rather than on
the terms of a few high up government
officials who wanted to play war clearly
there is a lot of depth to these options
which is help with the fact that unlike
the original game Invisible War actually
shows you the endings from a vision of
the future and not the present giving
the player a chance to actually
speculate on what the endings are about
rather than trying to piece together
what actually happened all things
considered Invisible War does go out in
a really strong way it's a shame that
the rest of the game couldn't pull its
weight though visible war is an
unfortunate creation while I can
recognize that a sequel to the original
was never going to be a masterpiece due
to DX's sheer level of quality Invisible
War is most definitely a few steps down
from that the game play was acceptable
and existed and this hollow feeling that
rarely sparked any sort of stimulation
in me was carried across the story the
idea of allying with factions was its
most Innovative idea but it was also its
biggest downfall as choices didn't
matter factions were designed not to go
against each other so the player could
experience all the content in one
playthrough and the few times it did
overlap La resulted in nothing more than
a simple consequence in the moment the
levels inside missions were also lacking
the life and energy that the previous
game had brought to the table missions
were more interesting when the context
of the reward and not the narrative
impact and the NPCs felt like talking
bodies rather than actual people as a
sequel to day ofx Invisible War is awful
but even as a standalone experience it
is still hopelessly
mediocre and that mediocrity is almost
what killed the series as after
Invisible War DSX would go under an
8-year Hiatus before the release of
2011's human Revolution a new game with
a new team new engine and new ideas
Human Revolution can be best summarized
as the modern day DSX it takes who made
the original game great but changes
things to fit a more modern audience
like Invisible War systems are
simplified so things flow more naturally
but it doesn't go too far augmentations
are easier to acquire and understand but
are more diverse allowing for tons of
replayability the Gunplay feels nicer
and smoother to use and many other
decisions why I do think new players to
the series should start with the
original DSX if for some odd reason
you're put off by its older systems or
don't have a PC handy Human Revolution
is a perfect substitute well there are
certainly a few things to be
disappointed about it's a game that's
better than the sum of its parts and
it's still to me the best game in the
series one thing that will be
immediately clear upon starting the game
is how much has changed 8 years is a
hell of a gap long enough to go through
a whole console generation meaning Human
Revolution is not working with the Xbox
360 and PS3 and thanks to this the game
is able to add more to the environments
than ever before areas are much larger
in this game sometimes doubling the
length of areas seen in the prior games
all of which are rarely separated by a
loading screen certain areas are closed
off and do require a whole new area to
load for them to function but you pretty
much go from end to end without ever
stopping these levels are also filled to
the brim with life each location is
chalk full of NPCs and extremely
complicated looking architecture that
probably took months to nail down you'll
also notice that the color scheme has
changed too going from a more dark and
impressive black and blue to more
inviting black and yellow so much in
fact that Whiz Khalifa might even enjoy
the game what what's Wild this edit
isn't even the game's final form as the
footage you're seeing is from the
director's cut Edition which among many
things removed much of the gold filter
that was present in the original well I
do think the new addition does look
better part of me always wish they
commit to the bit all the way to the end
among these locations are also quite a
few side quests that player can embark
on which further serve to flesh out the
world of human Revolution unlike the
first game though most of these missions
don't have multi-stage objectives like
our meeting with Sandra as they opted to
streamline the missions instead making
them easier and simpler to understand
however would it leaves behind it
replaces with its own story that fits
more in line with the game's theme Human
Revolution is a prequel to the entire
Series so in story order this is the one
you would play first well this is not
only a genius move on its own as this is
a game that is trying to Garner both old
and new fans so setting the game as the
first in the series means new fans
wanted to be caught up it also creates
an interesting dissonance within the
series as it sequel mankind divided
while later in the timeline is still
before the classic games which means if
you play the games in release order
you're going forward in technology but
backwards in time but forward in time
and backwards in technology if you
played in story order I would recommend
that you play it in release order though
as some of its story makes sense when
you have the full context of the past
two games this change in narrative that
I mentioned earlier though is regarding
its main thematic plot which is robot
racism to further explain both Human
Revolution and Mankind divided stories
hinge on the relationship between
augmentations and the people of the
world to many in this era of DSX
augmentations are more divisive than you
may think as some people find it to be
dangerous unregulated and unnatural
this is led to lots of political and
societal talks about what to do with
augmentations as they're clearly
supporters for each group most of the
game side quest and affirm main plot
revolve around augmentations and what
should be done with this new found piece
of technology it also poses some rather
interesting questions about our own
world and how we treat others as replace
augmentations with skin tone or
nationality and this is just textbook
racism the main difference and
counterargument for many within the game
world is that augmentations are not
mandatory and are all based on choice so
unlike skin tone these people chose to
have them in planted that's immediately
challenged in a variety of missions that
all deal with this subject matter take
for instance the literal protagonist of
the game Adam Jensen a man who works
security for serf Industries one of the
biggest suppliers of augmentations
throughout the world the start of the
game will have him killed while
defending the facility only for him to
wake up 6 months later with two new
mechanical arms while it's very
effective for his style of work he is
subjected to scrutiny that others would
receive even though he didn't have a
choice fortunately for Adam he is a
menacing looking killing machine so not
many people would want to challenge him
but for the rest of the common folk at
least to immense discrimination and
bigotry doubling down on this are three
side missions I count among the game's
best in terms of overall narrative and
how they portray the different ways of
the world the first one is centered
around an employee of sarif Industries
who's currently caught up in a scheme
but now wants out unfortunately the guy
he is working for has evidence of him
committing this scheme so he's using it
as blackmail to keep him on the team
what he was doing was sneaking out
Narine and giving it to the people in
need Narine is the drug that is used to
help the mechanically augmented use
their augments without their body
rejecting it since you're basically
attaching mechanical wires to an organic
nervous system the body blocks the
electrical signals it produces causing
it to be a little more than a paper
weight neopine removes these blockers in
the body allowing the augmentations to
function properly similar to Ambrosia
though it only lasts so long this time a
week of protection so augmented users
must get weekly doses for them to work
failure to administer this drug will
cause the body to build up tissue
creating more rejections which could
lead to something as small as dizziness
to something more harmful like seizures
or death so augmented people are
basically on a constant ticking timer
than needs to be reset in order to stay
alive due to this some people are unable
to afford those weekly Doses and that's
not even considering the people like
Adam who had a forced on them and now
not only can't pay for the surgery but
the lifetime supplies of neopine that
they'll need this is actually something
some gangs and thugs use to keep people
on their leash so to speak which is what
occurs in this other side mission as
this group of prostitutes that work for
this love Hotel of sorts are being asked
to get augmentations or they'll be fired
these women are likely not getting paid
that much anyway so the boss of the
hotel could use his money as leverage to
get them neopine meaning that being
fired after getting augmented will mean
no money and no neopine to pay for your
recently installed augments one of the
women working here asks us to find one
of her co-workers who was kidnapped by a
group of men who plan to do the same
thing Force augmentations onto her and
then be her main supplier of neuropathy
so she can't leave them in a slightly
different example there was another
woman named ja who owes money to the
Triads here in hangit China so we're
going to be their debt collector but as
you would expect the reason for the lack
of payment isn't some frivolous reason
Jai had always struggled in her life due
to her rough upbringing but was
determined to be better than her family
the problem is Ja was always behind her
top classmates not because she was bad
at school actually quite the opposite as
she was the top of her class but because
the rich kids just paid their way to the
top furthermore her career which as a
professional broker is filled with Rich
Kids with topthe line augmentations some
of which enhanced their work like being
able to see a person's feelings and
using that to win them over which is
actually something we can do in dialogue
sometimes Jai doesn't have money nor a
rich family so she needed help which is
why she went to the tries to set up a
loan despite being in different
circumstances augmentations were
something they either needed to get
ahead or was forced on them to keep
their job reinforcing that augmentations
aren't just cosmetic and more often than
not is something a person needs in their
life which makes the previous talk about
azine even worse as it's another pound
of baggage to add onto their lives it's
not only horrific to see how all these
people have become affected by these
inventions even though their whole
purpose was to uplift people but it's
also a grim reminder of the world we
live in today neopine and how it's being
distributed and used reminds me a lot of
the world's distribution of insulin
while I'm fortunate enough to not have
diabetes anyone with it can tell you
that buying insulin sucks similar to
azine diabetics need this in order to
survive as without it you could develop
diabetic keto acidosis which could be
life- threatening if not treated
historically though the price of insulin
has continued to grow every year now
reaching as high as $270 a vial with
most patients acquiring more than one or
two vials a month now while there has
been some talks of insulin being pushed
down to a much more affordable $35 a
month that's still an incredibly High
markup for something that people
literally need to survive while we can't
really determine a price for this kind
of thing in game we do know that just
like insulin there is a monopoly over
who produces anzine allowing them to
mark up the prices as they please
outside of the financial issues there's
also the more pressing societal issues
that come from being mechanically
augmented some people are surprisingly
open about their hostility towards these
things calling people augs which is
sometimes used as a slurt in the game to
some outright saying that a no augs
policy would be a fantastic idea the
people of this world are openly bigoted
towards their fellow humans simply
because they have augmentations and it w
to bring back segregation if it means
they don't get to see these people again
it's why the side quest not being as
complete as the original game still
works in human revolution's favor as
it's shifting its priorities to fit the
story it wants to tell the saying goes
that you shouldn't put all your eggs in
one basket but to be fair it's easier to
keep track of all those eggs if they're
in one place since the story is so
hyperfocused on one aspect of the
broader world they're able to keep
themselves on track without losing focus
we may not see the outcomes of these
individuals and how their lives will
have changed because of our help but but
we will be able to see in the moment how
their lives have been altered due to
this game's World defining
invention so the world of DSX is
discriminatory against people with
augmentations how does our protagonist
fa within this conflict well first we
have to explain how we got here the
first scene of the game starts with a
talk between members of the Illuminati
the only one we can see though is Bob
pagee since this game is a prequel many
of the characters who died are naturally
going to be alive again but don't get
used to seeing the Illuminati as this
will be the last time they appear
throughout the game following this is a
scene between Adam Jen and his
ex-girlfriend Megan Reed both work for
serif Industries but for different
reasons Jensen does security while Megan
is a scientist this creates some awkward
moments as it's the equivalent of your
ex being your cooworker you don't want
to see them but you still have to show
up to work there does seem to be some
unresolved feelings though as Megan has
a toy cop car in her office which was a
joke gift that she got herself since
Adam picked her up in a cop car for
their first date their Dynamic and how
it expertly showcase the feeling of Two
Lovers that fell apart but still love
each other in some way is also helped by
the fact that both of their voice Act
actors are married to each other as much
as I love JC though I have a real soft
spot for Adam his voice actor is Elias
defus whose most recent role was Sam Co
and Bethesda Starfield their voices are
so similar though that I've always
called Sam a space cowboy version of
Adam Jensen I never asked for this they
say they saved me but I'm not sure saved
is the right word this like many things
was likely done as a way to pay omage to
its old The Roots as both protagonists
wear trench coats and glasses despite
the attire being completely unnecessary
moreover Robinson and Pritchard are
similar in that they both serve as the
hacker friend of the protagonist and
jock our old pilot is now replaced with
farita Malik the game's music is also
trying to replicate the synthetic sounds
of the original and as a nice not to
that score radios throughout the game
might play tracks directly from the
original soundtrack thex is an important
series and one that needed to be handled
with care it's clear that idos Montreal
wanted to keep the original in mind as
they too saw what made the first game
great and so dedicated their time to
making sure they could do that with
their game unlike the music which I
still think goes the original day ofx
the cast of human revolution is one I
enjoy more both prit and Malik have
their own unique personalities and even
their own missions that the player can
assist them with farita is a Charming
pilot who will help Jensen to get where
he needs to go her Mission takes place
in hsha where she wants Jensen to look
into her friend's death that she
believes was mishandled kind to find out
it was as the boyfriend found out that
she was pregnant and killed her to make
it look like an accident so he didn't
have to raise the kid it's a pretty
brutal tale but given how nice Malik is
it's only fair that we help her in a
time of need she like also has a
circumstance that can determine their
fate back in the original before leaving
the Illuminati headquarters you can find
a mechanic who's doing an absolutely
poor job at hiding the fact that he is
not a mechanic if you need more proof
though you can find the body of the
actual mechanic nearby reporting this to
jock has him remark how a bomb was
attached to the helicopter but thanks to
JC he was able to remove it Malik gets
in her own bind when the helicopter
crashes and you can choose to leave or
help her resulting in her death if you
choose the former Pritchard on the other
hand is incredibly annoying but it's how
he was designed
he and Jensen go back and forth all the
time ripping on each other for even the
smallest things and while it's annoying
there's some of my favorite types of
characters as they always seem to have
some issue that needs solving which
usually makes them come around to the
protagonist which is what happens with
Pritchard regarding some security issue
with the company that turns into an
investigation into Jensen's past that
said for annoying as he can be he has
some pretty good taste in games as
located in the back of his office is a
poster for Final Fantasy 27 while the
team behind the game was idos Montreal
idos interactive is owned by Square Enix
so out quite optimistic of them to
assume though that we would be on Final
Fantasy 27 by the year 2027 since it's
already 2023 and we're only on 16
getting to the point I really like the
cast of this game and while not all of
them will reappear in the sequel they
were still able to make a likable cast
of characters within the limited screen
time that they were
given returning to the plot while Jensen
follows Megan we get a pretty good look
at what goes on behind the scenes at
sarif Industries and one major criticism
of augmentations is its use in Warfare
War over the years has gotten deadlier
and more destructive and this augmented
Tech would further push that boundary
such as this Typhon launcher which
launches a spread of grenades around the
user inflicting harm on anyone nearby
which while bad enough as is is made all
the worse when we too can use this Tech
meaning anyone with enough money could
just buy this and take out quite a few
innocent people Megan does assure both
us and Jensen that while some of their
contracts are from the Department of
Defense her goal is specifically to
enhance the human body not destroy it
which is where she is currently taking
us as Megan is set to present a recent
finding of hers that for a lack of a
better word will knock the parts of our
DNA that have always been hidden the
wording there is quite specific and has
been used to Plate most people who see
augmentations as new things added to the
body as this would simply unlock what
was already there it's eventually
learned though that this discovery was
because of Adam another connection to
the original games that the main
character is not a normal everyday
person but an experiment crafted by an
organization Adam as a kid was taken to
a place called White Helix Labs where
the kids would undergo gene therapy
experiments all the kids ended up dying
except Adam which is why his genes were
so important two workers couldn't bear
the guilt of working there though so
they burned the whole facility down and
had Adam taken to his family so they
would raise him on his own all of this
happened not only without his consent
but without his knowledge as Adam has no
idea about this unless you complete a
very specific side quest which on that
topic this game includes a surprising
amount of hands-off moments like this
where details are mentioned or quests
are given without requiring the player
to do them the origin of Adam and why he
is so special is a side quest when
usually this would be fit into the main
script somehow but it wasn't as the game
isn't about Adam but augmentations as a
whole as a result though Adam is the
only person in the world that we know of
who doesn't need neopine because his
body bonds so well with his
augmentations that blockers aren't
necessary this is the discovery that
Megan wants to present as if they could
take Adam's DNA replicate it then put it
in a biochip people could share all the
same qualities that he has meaning the
robaz would no longer be needed now once
again Adam has no idea about this and
won't be told unless you figure it out
for yourself so to him he's just
escorting his ex-girlfriend to a meeting
that is until his meeting with the
company CEO David serif where an alarm
goes goes off during their talk forcing
them to cut it short so we can figure
out what happened what he originally
thought was a bad accident turns into a
complete hostile takeover as three spec
op members of a private military group
called Bell Tower have attacked the
facility with the intention of
destroying their work and taking Megan
and her scientists with them this is
where Adam is killed only to be awoken 6
months later with new arms however
similar to RoboCop just because you're
dead doesn't mean you can't come into
work as Adam is naturally back to
working with sarif as security and he
already has a new job for him one of
their industrial plans is being attacked
by pro-human group who hate
augmentations So Adam has to go down
there and get rid of the attackers from
the start though the game is trying to
plan breadcrumbs that point to a much
larger conspiracy going on as within
their ranks as a hacker with neuro
augmentations something quite rare for a
pro-human group the guy's body is later
examined which does confirm that he is
indeed augmented along with a location
of another hacker who is working off
site away from the conflict following
this lead brings us to a remote facility
which is of course owned by the ever
nefarious FEMA unfortunately FEMA is
rarely mentioned in this game outside of
the this one interaction but referring
to our prior discussion they really are
rounding up people and putting them in
interment camps just like the old
conspiracy claim they did guarding these
places not only more of the bell tower
guys but the same spec ops guards that
killed Jensen 6 months ago these three
are part of the game's three boss fights
and they are quite disappointing human
revolution's development was tight as
such the team needed to Outsource some
of the production to get things ready
and on time one of which was the boss
fights and it seems like the original
team knew this wasn't up to par with
their standards as the Director cut
specifically add new changes to these
fights alone but it's like the old
analogy I love to use which is putting a
Band-Aid over a bullet wound the
director's cut can only do so much to
solve the problem but it won't fix it
permanently as the problem is never on
the outer edges of its design the entire
core needs to be ripped out and replaced
if it's going to fix it I say this
because each fight is more or less a
competition to see who can pepper the
other with bullets faster Take yona's
Fight For example her boss fight is this
large circular room with lots of cover
and a Few Lockers to take ammo from in
the original this was the only location
the director cut adds doors to either
side which give you access to a second
floor where you either disperse gas into
the room below or hack the turrets to
fight for you you might be seeing the
problem already though as all the
director's cut does is give you more
flavors of death there is a severe lack
of conversational and non-lethal options
in this entry going non-lethal is a
valid strategy but the following cut
scene creates an immense disconnect
tonally as you can use a stun gun for
the whole fight only for the cut scene
to make it look like you coated them
with bullets also despite the game
having a very in-depth conversational
system it refuses is to let you talk to
these three and possibly talk them down
as a result this mechanic also comes
from an augmentation so it's not
something every player will have
available to them and it allows you to
choose dialogue options related to their
personality so you can get what you want
out of them yet you weren't able to use
it for the fight mechanically they are
quite a mess of times but I find that it
struggles just as much narratively is
the only connection we have to them is
that they were the ones who attacked
Jensen 6 months ago all we know is that
they were hired by the Illuminati to
make sure things go their way which is a
real step down from the prior DSX games
is there was at least some kind of
relation reltionship with these
individuals that gave you a chance to
understand them more human revolutions
boss fights feel can attempt to cash in
on the industry trend of including boss
fights in games even though it didn't
really need
any killing Barrett provides Jensen with
his next location Hena China which is
where we'll find our hacker just like
Detroit hanga has its own problems of
augmentations but the visuals refuse to
back down as the game is just as
gorgeous as before maybe even better in
some ways it's truly impressive just how
well this game holds up 12 years later
some of the character models have
definitely shown their age and the
game's use of FMV cut scen instead of
in-engine ones is a surprising but not
wholly unwelcome choice but the actual
environments themselves haven't aged a
day hiding within the city is our hacker
windmill through him we find out who
hired him which was ta Young Medical CEO
Zhao who is SF industry's biggest
competitor talking to him allows us to
get an employee card that'll give us
access to their headquarters so we can
meet Z herself as you've likely noticed
by now this entire plot has been one
wild goose chase and it's only going to
get worse as what halts our current
Chase is yet another one when Mei with Z
she talks about how Megan's tee was fit
with GPL trackers that allow serif to
keep track of their movements the reason
we haven't found them yet is because
people who are higher up than her have
disabled them these higher up people
she's referring to are the Illuminati Z
is a member of this group so this is
just one of their legitimate businesses
that they can use to laer cash through
while also using its influence to
control the market as their plans to
eventually monopolize the entire
augmentation industry with serif being
the only one left standing to add
another step in our Chase Z has been
seen talking with Eliza kassan the
biggest news anchor in the world so
Eliza is either working for them or at
least knows what's going on this is when
Jensen will discover that Megan and her
team are actually alive at the time
pretty much everyone assumed that they
were all dead but not everyone was
convinced there's even a side quest from
Megan's Mom where you can look into the
investigation of her death to find any
inconsistencies so in its defense the
reveal is quite the Revelation and a
fine part of the game but it's this part
that I was talking about we go from
finding a hacker to now finding Megan I
got to be honest the whole princess is
in another Castle Trope is is one of my
least favorite ideas in any medium the
reason I hate the Trope so much is
because it's an easy way to extend a
story on the guys that it's actually
going somewhere we are no closer to
finding Megan now than we were 8 hours
ago and we still have another eight to
go before we finally meet her it's not
even possible to analyze the plot any
deeper than we've already gone because
all you'll end up getting is Megan
that's the central plot of human
Revolution find Megan and while there
were many fun side quests to do along
the way when you isolate the main plot
you start to see the issue to continue
on though before I start acting like the
the game and delaying the plot all the
way to the end the finale of this
section has us meeting with Eliza only
to find out that she is in AI which is
how she's able to keep up with her 247
news coverage upon learning about all
this we then return to Detroit which is
when the riots start to happen people
are firebombing buildings causing havoc
and generally making a mess of the city
all because it was learned that sarif
Industries was creating super soldiers
with their new augmentation technology
hoping to tip the scales in his favor
Bill tager a member of the humanity
front a pro-human organization is
holding a speech today regarding these
events we plan to attend this meeting as
talking with him will lead us to his AE
sandavol who will lead us to Megan as
according to him the GBL trackers are
still online what are being broadcasted
at a frequency that is so low no one
would be wise enough to look there
thanks to this pitchard is able to track
one of the scientists except we discover
that it's not the scientist but rather a
man named Tong who took the arm of the
scientist and used it for himself he
refuses to give up the location of the
team or where he thinks the team is
located until we do him a solid which is
to rescue his son who happens to be
Tracer Tong from the classic games Tong
will then give us a location of a port
where he wants to plant a bomb this
explosion will not only [__] Bell
Tower but will also distract the people
here long enough for us to sneak into a
cryopod onto a ship that's supposedly
headed to Megan and her team do you see
why I don't like this goose chase stuff
what have I said in the past 5 minutes
that has been genuinely interesting and
not a summarization of the plot
thankfully the gameplay is able to pull
its weight making these moments still
enjoyable but from a story perspective
we reached a real low point in the
quality of the writing and it's about to
hit the lowest point possible as we're
about to go on yet another 2hour detour
tour while usually save my talks about
the DLC towards the end the director's
cut of human Revolution integrated the
DLC into the main story said it was more
seamless than before but it also caused
the game to drag on even longer than it
already is human revolution's only DLC
The Missing Link is such a bizarre piece
of content as it's trying so hard to be
like DX's fifth mission where JC is
captured but it's doing it poorly Jensen
like JC is captured and has to scavenge
gear in order to survive except unlike
JC Jensen also lost his augments too the
game will give you both your weapons and
some upgrade kitss but it's not as many
augments as you likely had and your
weapons don't come with any ammo so they
just take up 90% of your inventory and
serve no purpose my biggest problem was
actually these augments as the game was
forcing me to buy back some of the
augments I've already gotten when I
could have just gotten new ones that I
hadn't purchased yet the fun of that
escape mission was being able to use
your augments while you were still
searching for your gear removing the
augments severely cuts down the amount
of options the player has because I
highly doubt many players were going to
Reby the augments just to get them back
later anyway now now to be fair the game
doesn't give you your augments back
directly only the kits used to upgrade
them so I kind of screwed myself over by
withholding them the whole time thinking
they were just going to come back online
somehow but I still think it is a bit
much to remove all of them at the start
of the DLC to continue the theme of
connection not only do we have our own
datalist who is helping us Escape but
this research facility is a very
important base to Bell Tower and
subsequently the Illuminati so in both
cases we're learning more about our
enemies while we Traverse through the
levels the main objective at the moment
is to escape only to find out that one
of the members of Bel Tower was
contacted by interpole in order to help
them take the group down from the inside
the methods of what goes on here though
are its strongest story beat as Bell
Tower is apparently kidnapping people
for the hin project this hin project is
basically a large supercomputer that is
connected to a group of human beings who
use these drones to help it operate the
two doctors here Gary Savage which was a
nice Cameo and Tiffany Kavanaugh are
being forced by Bell Tower to test the
subjects they bring in so that they can
create suitable host for the superc
computer as a side project they're also
being asked by DARPA to see if this kind
of kind of Technology can be applied to
the military as they want to be able to
track their soldiers down and check
their combat awareness so basically the
plot of Metal Gear Solid 4 after
confronting Dr Kavanaugh we can ask her
to work with us to bring Bell Tower down
which she agrees to do stopping us from
doing all this is of all things a
loading screen since the game decided to
waste more of your time for whatever
reason as it has you go through these
scans every time you enter a new area of
the ship and you'll often have to cross
these multiple times as you have to
report back to these people when the
objective is complete
I know it's a bit of an odd thing to
bring up but it becomes very annoying to
go through these after the sixth or
seventh time which is rather odd since
the main game doesn't have any of this
the only loading screens that exist are
when new areas are entered not something
like this which is clearly disguised as
a loading screen either way the DLC for
as middle of the road as its story is
does have a really fascinating ending as
reforce to choose between Dr kavana or
the capture prisoners on the ship the
reason I call it fascinating is if you
instead refuse to make a choice you
could explore the prison area of the
ship and find a vent that takes you to
where the gap G is being dispersed
letting you save both groups at the same
time it's a wonderful inclusion into the
game as like the original it wants to
avoid giving the player a set of binary
options but it also doesn't want to let
the player choose the obviously correct
choice so it refuses to call attention
to it this will only be found by players
who explore enough and by those who
refuse to accept that there are only two
options and it's good to see that the
game is adding choices like this this
deep into the story the very final scene
of the DLC has us talking with our
datalist who was actually just the
weapons Merchant you meet earlier all
this conversation really does is set up
a group of individuals called the
Juggernaut Collective who are enemies of
the Illuminati it's a nice addition but
they only show up in the sequel so this
won't amount to much until we actually
get to that game after this Jensen will
then go into another cryopod but this
time it takes him to Megan's lab in
Singapore and here is also her entire
team that will have to rescue in order
to proceed around here is where we meet
with Zhao but it's on a boss fight with
her as you still have to fight namir his
fight is actually one I quite liked a z
was able to disable your augmentations
leaving you permanently EMP if you did
did a very specific Choice upon entering
hang show for the second time Jensen
will experience a bit of a short circuit
along with all the other augmented
people in the vicinity something
happened to the chips on a global level
so everyone is urged to visit a clinic
to get the new Chips the timing of this
seems rather convenient and it is
because the Illuminati planned this so
the new Chips would become the industry
standard which would also come equip
with technology that they can use to
control people allowing the Illuminati
to literally control people on a
worldwide scale PCH advises Jensen to
visit one and if you do then you're
affected by the em P but if you choose
not to then you just continue the fight
as normal and are allowed to use your
augmentations again similar to the
choice in the DLC it's another example
of this game's hands-off approach to its
choices this option is only mentioned
once by Pritchard and it's not even
really an option as the game never gives
you a quest marker or any kind of
objective to visit the clinic he just
says hey you should visit a clinic and
you can if you want to but if you do
you'll get consequences hours down the
line after about 16 hours of playing we
finally come face to face with Megan and
it's here where the story starts to take
a very deadly turn as on screen is Hugh
daro the creator of augmentations who is
currently holding a speech at the base
of his new project called Pancha what
follows is horrifying to say the least
as he activates a button which turns all
augmented people psychotic causing them
to kill anything in sight and not just
in the room but around the world in
order to stop the biggest Mass killing
in history our goal is to go to this
Pancha and stop the broadcast Pena is
the final level in the game and just
like the games before it this is where
we get to meet the leaders and choose
our ending the first one by default is
huero who despite being a Madman does
have his reasons see he knew about the
Illuminati and what they plan to do with
the biochips so he came to the obviously
logical conclusion that the Illuminati
can't control what doesn't exist so
killing augmented people would prevent
them from being controlled the issue is
that that is an incredibly flawed look
at the situation hudo naively thinks
that some good will come out of this but
we can convince him that yeah he might
be the philanthropist hudo today but
tomorrow he'll be known as the biggest
mass murderer in history his
counterargument though is that the
people will be able to see through the
corruption and understand that he needed
to do this but I highly doubt they'll be
able to see that far with all the piles
of dead bodies in the way what's quite
unexpected of him is that despite being
the father of augmentations he actually
thinks Humanity should evolve naturally
without their use anymore but this isn't
due to some moral decision to let people
be free or something it's driven from a
petty view of jealousy because
ironically enough he's one of the few
individuals in the world that can't use
augmentations he is the opposite to
Jensen wherein no matter how much
neopine he takes his body always rejects
it which is a rather fitting fate for
someone like him for his ending he wants
to broadcast a message to the world that
unveils the truth about the Illuminati
and how the secret group everyone thinks
is a dumb conspiracy is actually real if
we want to though we can instead edit
the message and create a fake narrative
that puts the blame on a different group
these two endings come from sarif and
tager who unlike the previous games are
endings you can miss as once again the
game only suggests that you can save
them here in Pancha but never gives you
the location or writes it in your quest
log serif suggests that you spin the
story and put the blame on tagert and
his people at Humanity front claiming
that they turned to biological warfare
to kill augmented people tagert on the
other hand wants you to say that a bad
batch of neopine was distributed and
contaminated people for a time which is
what caused the disturbance he also
makes a note that while he is pro-human
he doesn't want to remove augmentations
only regulate them like Invisible War
though we can also opt to refuse and
instead destroy Pancha which would kill
serif Darrow tager and us meaning that
no one would be able to spin the story
letting Humanity decide what happened
for themselves
while all great this is why I've been so
vocal about the main plot as we have
spent 16 hours searching for a woman we
lost 30 minutes in only to choose an
ending between three men we barely
interacted with all game we have talked
to dagger and Tarot twice and siif maybe
three or four times of most and all I
have to show for it is that one wants to
continue augmentation research one wants
to destroy it and one wants to regulate
it say what you will about Invisible War
but at least we got to see the factions
for ourselves and learn about their
beliefs and values human Revolution does
none of that as it instead thought it'd
be better to focus on our goose chase
what makes things worse is the endings
themselves not only are the endings
literal buttons on a computer quite
possibly the laziest way I've ever seen
it done but more damning is that a Liza
tells you what will happen if you choose
a specific ending according to her if we
choose Darrow's ending the world will
reject augmentations and the people will
live freely but why is this being shown
before I make a decision isn't that what
the end slides are supposed to be the
beauty of the Omar ending from Invisible
War is the consequences of the world
falling to R came after your heroic
Triumph of defeating all the leaders at
once had the game mentioned this fate
before enacting the ending it would have
lost all its meaning Human Revolution
spoils its own endings before you're
even allowed to choose which doesn't
make sense at all idos Montreal also
made the interesting choice of
committing so hard to the Illuminati
being a shadow organization by making
them a complete Shadow throughout the
whole story I told you we wouldn't see
them until after the intro which begs
the question of why they was even there
to begin with the cherry on top of all
of this is that the final boss that
stops US is one of the worst fights I've
ever done done in my life the final boss
of the game is Zhao because that makes
sense to stop her all we have to do is
pull down these levers which house these
human drones we saw from the DLC which
now that I think about it was probably
an incredibly weird experience to have
without the DLC as these women are only
shown in that extra piece of content
maybe that's why it's called The Missing
Link after the women have been killed
all you have to do is sit on this ledge
and wait as Z electrocute the floor but
this wall will save you from it entirely
then you just wait 3 minutes for her to
break the glass and then shoot her
mechanically it's a mess and narratively
like the other bosses has no real impact
as Z has done absolutely nothing since
the start of the game yes she is a
member of the Illuminati and the CEO of
Sarah's biggest competitor but that's
just her story she isn't actually doing
anything in the game itself Walter on
the other hand took control of unatco
sent troops to kill us and turned on our
kill switch all in an effort to stop us
Z has done nothing of the sort which is
why he was actually baffled that she was
the final boss from top to bottom these
last 20 minutes are pretty bad which
ultimately leaves her rather sour
aftertaste when playing but just like I
said before Human Revolution is better
than the sum of its parts is if you look
at it from a more broad perspective
looking at it as a game and not sections
of content that make up a game Human
Revolution is without question a
fantastic and well-made product while I
do have my gripes the positives of its
design are so strong that it easily
overshadows anything that attempts to
bring it down it may have a
disappointing ending a goose chase of a
plot in some mediocre boss fights but
its theme of discrimination its
characters world and its gameplay are
some of the best if not the best in the
series to date Jensen and Company are
extremely likable having the story shift
towards a more central theme of
mechanical racism was a surprising but
welcome choice and its decision to only
focus on that one aspect of the writing
allowed the team to divert all the
willpower towards the one goal of
creating a homogeneous World under
discrimination and the gameplay while
not talked about much in this video is
simply fantastic it feels fluid and is
without those rough edges that the other
games came with it is truly the perfect
example of what a modern reimagining of
a classic DSX game could look like and
by doing so the team shot the series in
a mainstream appeal racking in more
sales than ever before with human
Revolution passing both Invisible War
and the original DX's lifetime sales in
just a few weeks DSX had finally hit the
main stream and there was a sense that
the team was just getting started as
while they left many things unanswered
or unexplored like Pancha the Illuminati
and many of its key characters it seems
that the team didn't miss the
opportunity to talk about it but rather
decided to wait until the time was
right mankind divided has a reputation
of being more of the same and that is
not something I disagree with from its
gameplay to its story it's honestly just
a prettier version of human Revolution
with the occasional new change here and
there and your feelings about human
Revolution Will carefully illustrate
your thoughts on mankind divided either
just more good or more bad there someone
who enjoyed the prior entry this was
right at my alley Human Revolution is
not the only game it's copying though as
it's also taking a few pages out of
Invisible War as instead of the collapse
we now have the AUG incident often
shorten to the incident the difference
is when these events occur in and their
respective games Invisible War took
place 20 years after the collapse
mankind divided is 2 years after the
incident 20 years is a long time hell
I've only been alive for 23 and that
time was reflected in the environment
people were doing quite well for
themselves in locations while
occasionally run down and deserted
looked a lot better off than you would
imagine the world that moved past the
collapse and evolved like we humans
usually do we take it on the chin and
move on doing what we can to make the
most of the situation no matter how bad
it is when mankind divided the incident
is still fresh that attack that hudo
triggered in the last game is still
being discussed and people are still
experiencing the ramifications of it
it's had time to sink in and fester
corrupting the minds of the people that
were alive to witness it everyone is
still mourning over the deaths that
occurred as a result of the attack
people are fearing for their lives and
are actively avoiding anyone with
augmentations just in case it happens
again all while those that were affected
are on the receiving end of this hatred
leaving them broken wondering how
something like this could happen
questioning why they would attack the
people they love and are also just as
afraid of leaving their houses 20 years
was too long 2 years is just right as it
throws you right into the heart of the
conflict and just like human Revolution
the game does just as well if not a
better job at conveying the horrors of
living in a world as a mechanical human
thanks to the incident many laws have
been put in place which were designed to
segregate and eliminate augmented people
random Security checks are made by the
police when they deem a specific person
to be suspicious which is pretty much
all the time augmented people are also
forced to go through various check
points just across into certain areas
and the Subways have been segregated
with quote unquote Naturals or regular
humans getting their own subway car away
from the augmented theine dependency is
also at an all-time high since SF
Industries actually went bankrupt
following the attack with Tai Young
Medical buying up the company giving
them a monopoly over the market thear
razine is now a rare commodity almost as
valuable as gold to some people which
you the player can actually trade with
granting useful items and info so not
only are augmented people being beat in
the street but the drug they need to
survive is rare and extremely expensive
some people are so shook by the side
effects in the world around them that
they feel like they have no choice but
to give up like this one woman woman who
asked if I could kill her but not make
it super bloody as she still wants her
family to identify her when she's dead
or this family who is debating whether
to have a child both for financial and
social reasons as the kid would have to
grow up with augmented parents but you
know how it goes push someone long
enough and it's only a matter of time
until they push back and that push in
this case is domestic terrorism as
numerous bombings and shootings have
occurred throughout the world with the
perpetrators mostly if not all being
people with augments this while a
temporary solution for some has created
a permanent solution for the rest of the
world as those who augmented are now
being punished for their acts similarly
discrimination and bigotry has increased
even more since then and is once again
another unfortunate occurrence that our
world shares with the game as following
any major incident or attack anyone who
just so happens to look like the people
that are responsible for it are always
going to be affected Muslims are
ridiculed and subject to hate crimes
thanks to the attacks in 2001 and many
Asians all over the world were verbally
or even physically abused because of Co
since it originated in Wuhan China it's
horrible but the game does a wonderful
job of showing these horor to you by
ironically shoving it in your face as
you can't go a few minutes without
someone either calling you an Aug or
seeing someone be attacked simply for
their augmentations just like the
previous game the squ quests also have a
heavy focus on this aspect of the world
but this time they Amplified the
intensity before it was Quest involving
augmented people and some of the
Discrimination they face but it was
always just a few bad apples after the
incident it's now rare to find someone
who is actually proog which leads to
those who are augmented to stick
together creating a further disconnect
between the two groups one of the
earliest examples is once again one the
best missions in the game as upon
leaving his apartment Jensen is stopped
by a cop who asks for his papers he
hands them to the cop willing to
discover that they are out of date and
that the new ones just came in that he
needs to get Jensen finds this absurd
but plays along as the cop instructs him
to go to a forger he knows since he
sympathizes with augs in actuality he's
just extorting you for money since not
only are the prices of the forgeries
35,000 credits but he's not even a real
cop he just set up this checkpoint to
make a quick Buck on the less fortunate
it's a lot like those scam emails you
likely get every day no one with an
ounce of computer knowledge would fall
for this stuff but Al those scammers
need are a few people that are either
too careless or too desperate to notice
not having your papers in this
post-incident world of day ofx is a
major offense and will get you sent to
Golem City a place completely designed
to house augmented people it's like a
civilized concentration camp people can
hold jobs and do normal everyday things
but they can't leave the city are
watched by police 24/7 and are as likely
to be robbed by a fellow Aug than they
are to get shot in the street by police
it's a horrible place to live and no one
in the city seems to enjoy their time
there making these people's lives even
more miserable than they already are
within this side quest though we can
actually meet the woman making the
forgeries and we come to learn that she
has good intentions but the people
working with her are the ones extorting
people for money so she offers us a
chance to help a few people by getting
them some fake passports talking with
them really gives you a sense of how the
world treats these people arena for
instance seems to have split personality
disorder referring to herself as Helena
which usually manifest from intense
trauma and given the world right now
it's not far off to assume that this
personality of hers was great to stop
her mind from breaking Edward on the
other hand is a store owner who is seen
getting robbed by the time we arrive he
goes on to explain that when the
incident happened he was with his family
and that the attack caused him to kill
his grandchild as a result his family
caught off contact with him and now he
has no one in his life he stays here in
Prague though because he wants to be
close to his family even if they don't
want him we end up helping these two out
by giving them passports only to
discover that we can only activate one
choosing one causes the other to end up
in Golem City so by attempting to do
some good we end up making one person's
life even worse than before
to further add to this some people have
opted to search Elsewhere for answers
most augmented people live in the sewers
and quite a few people can either be
found at the church of the machine God
or at this underground magic show the
church believes that all augmented
people are in actuality blessed by the
world and will evolve into what's known
as The Singularity where they all merge
into one Consciousness and transcend
death there is a splinter group within
the church though that we end up running
into during a main quest where they
believe in something called the
Ascension as opposed to the singularity
which is roughly the same thing except
they also merge with the machine God
themselves elves and become one the
magic show on the other hand was
designed by a former magician to help
the augmented live Carefree lives away
from the harm and dangers of the real
world the only way he was able to
achieve that though was by hypnotizing
them into believing what he says but
while his methods were nefarious his
goal is commendable as he was able to
create a small piece of heaven here in
the sewers as all the members have all
the Necessities they need and never need
to leave but this obviously came at the
cost of their free will it's pretty easy
to see this stuff as absurd especially
the religion bit since it was just made
up recently after the incident so
there's likely not a whole lot of proof
to their religious claims but it shows
that these people truly believe that
they have no way out so they try to find
comfort in something anything just so
they don't throw themselves off the
nearest roof outside of the here and now
there are also plenty of things
happening in the background that add to
the horror Chief among them being the
human restoration act a bill that if
passed will call for the removal and
downgrade of all powerful and unlicensed
augmentations it would also Force
control chips to be put into anyone who
is augmented which would presumably let
the owners of the chips track their
movements and maybe even notri control
them and there was also a test going on
for augmented people by ta Young Medical
which has volunteers who are clearly not
mentally stable have certain implants
put into them hoping to cure them of
that deficiency ideally this would help
those with depression overcome it as
they would have an implant of someone's
DNA put into them that doesn't have
depression but this backfired when one
of the patients was given the DNA of a
serial killer causing her to kill
augmented people by ripping out their
limbs and letting them bleed to death it
is hard to get a grasp on when this
happened though as the killer Daria was
a patient before the incident
but ta Young Medical also ran out of
packages to use so they offered
prisoners to scan their DNA because
that's a logical thing to do but none of
this seems to have happened as a result
of the incident still since her killings
occur during the events of the game it
continues to make things worse for
augmented people is now they have a
serial killer on the loose that only
targets them and the police seem to not
be losing any sleep over this since most
seem to chalk this up as an accident or
just ignore the murder entirely since
the victim was augmented the world of
DSX has not been kind to augmented
people and it's only gotten worse a
staggering 89% of augmented people prior
to the incident have been killed leaving
only 7 million people left in the world
and no matter where they go they're
always facc with some kind of ridicule
and discrimination and seeing his Jensen
is augmented himself he too is faced
with the same level of scrutiny not just
from the police but from common everyday
people those police checkpoints Force
Jensen to hand over his papers every
time you pass and unlike the missing
link DLC this is not an excuse to hide a
loading screen as most of this occurs
right before you leave the Metro which
is where the actual loading screen
occurs this was 100% deliberately made
to stop your play time and to piss you
off and while it most definitely did as
it ruins the flow of exploration and
gameplay constantly it was designed to
do exactly that some people on the
street also attempt to antagonize him
but given he's still a brick [__] house
with retractable blades in his arms no
one's really going to give him any
issues within all the violence and death
though are lights in the darkness people
that are willing to fight the good fight
on behalf of the augmented the two main
groups are Ark and Sam's dad ark or the
augmented rights Coalition fight for the
fair treatment of all augmented citizens
and Sam's dad is a self-publishing
magazine that seeks to spread the truth
they don't personally do this for
augmented people it just so happens that
most of the fake news spread throughout
the world is made to paint augmented
people in a negative light so they do
help them on occasion both of these
groups don't fight violently however as
the battles are done diplomatically as
they both attempt to spread the truth
and make sure people are treated fairly
mainstream media is doing its best to
shut them down though like pus TV still
run by Eliza cassan who has been
fabricating and twisting more stories in
order to drum up controversy by claiming
that those recent terrorist attacks were
done by members of in order to make them
look bad like I said it's a pretty evil
world and thanks to Jensen being the
main character the player gets to
experience this stuff firsthand it's not
just that Jensen is being harassed or
cursed at it's the player too and the
dialogue system lets you express
yourself further than ever before by
letting you internalize those emotions
or unleash them if a guy wrongs you
should you kill them because of how they
treated you what would the public think
would I be no better than what they
think I am on the other hand though if
they already see me as the villain then
why should I try to be anything but that
it's a rather impressive way to
structure a story and its dialogue and
just like human Revolution mankind
divided does an incredible job of
creating a world that is overrun with
racism and hatred while also letting the
player be the target of those attacks
letting them experience firsthand the
horrors of the world they're in and then
letting them come to a decision as to
how they want the world to perceive
them you might have noticed though that
all this talk has been about the
incident the thing that occurred in the
last game the thing which had no barring
on any of our endings which begs the
question mankind divided is a sequel
what ending did it go with well the
answer might surprise you in that idos
Montreal chose none of them all right
saying none is technically lying it's
more like all of them are Canon but the
game does its best to invalidate them
anyway making it feel like none so
firstly the how well according to the
writers behind the game thanks to all
the media coverage and news surrounding
the attack Jensen was able to get the
message he chose out to the world but it
was buried underneath everything else
that came out at the time yes somehow
Eliza kassan one of the most
recognizable people in the world who
owns a 20 247 news station watched by
billions couldn't get the message out to
the world as other information was
circling the net sure on top of this
pane was so structurally weak anyway
that the place was going to collapse
regardless of if they pressed the button
for that ending either like I said all
of them are Cannon but the game goes to
Great Lengths to make it feel like your
choice was meaningless once again though
I am okay with the direction of the
endings as the only important part was
the incident the thing that occurred
outside of the ending and having the
endings not have any weight means the
script could focus on the topic at hand
still sucks that this was the result
though as for Jensen well he managed to
survive the collapse along with David
serif however he had to be taken to a
clinic in Alaska so they could operate
on him which brings us to today 2029 2
years after the previous game where
Jensen is now working for interpole
whose job is to track down and take out
International terrorists he is of course
the only Aug on the strike team in the
whole task force it seems which doesn't
really help him much but he is naturally
the most capable of the bunch the
current mission is to find their contact
who's been working undercover with the
Jin who sell and manufacture Black
Market Goods
once we arrive at the meeting site
everything goes well until the deal is
broken up by mysterious men in Gold
masks these guys are called The Shadow
operatives the Illuminati henchmen while
a rather simplistic Mission not only is
this a great tutorial as it gives Jensen
access to most of his augments allowing
you to experiment with them now so you
can buy them when they inevitably are
reset but it also shows how many fingers
the Illuminati has in the world's pie
and by God do these guys have fingers
these [__] double dip their way into
everything in this game and the sole
reason for just about everything that
goes on in the world whether that's
something that's already happened or
things that are about to happen Jensen
is not without help though as he is
teamed up with a woman named Alex Vega
who's a member of the Juggernaut
Collective the same group that the
missing link DLC alluded to earlier they
are mortal enemies of the Illuminati and
will butt heads with them at just about
every single interval throughout the
story unfortunately just like the
previous game their time in the script
is incredibly short the jugut collective
only extends to the few talks of Vega
and one meeting with Janus the group's
leader in the Illuminati is once again
given one and only one cut scene to
characterize themselves with it is
admittedly a lot better than the first
game as we actually get to see some of
the old guard return or I guess new
guard since narratively this is their
first appearance either way Bob Page is
back once again but now joined by Morgan
Everett Lucius De Beers someone who I
didn't mention but we can meet back in
the first game and some other members
that we know of but haven't seen before
like Elizabeth declair nicolette's
mother their role in all this is to make
sure the human restoration act passes
likely due to the control chip part of
the act so orchestrating events to make
sure that they go the way they want
whether that be a bombing by members of
ark or Robbie that didn't actually
happen the collective is trying to
prevent them from doing this and Jensen
while not officially working for them
will assist them from time to time while
in Prague Jensen is here to meet with
the task force so they can figure out
what happened in Dubai only for a
bombing to occur at the train station
almost killing them both while it is
once again an incredible start I
garnered a much more negative opinion
about this later as we are once again
going on a goose chase but this one ends
in such a bizarre way the main objective
as of now is to figure out who who
carried out this bombing except we don't
learn who it is in fact you won't learn
who because it's answered in the DLC
that I'll eventually get to later the
game does at least refused to drag it on
for the entirety of the game and decides
to focus on a few more interesting paths
in the narrative first which involve
working with Vega to determine if our
boss Miller is working with the
Illuminati and skipping the bomber
entirely by not finding who did it but
rather who ordered the hit which sees us
going to Golem City and talking to the
leader of Arc Talos Rucker as he is the
most likely suspect both of these
missions actually end up converging on
each other due to the subject matter as
while investigating Miller Jensen learns
that his boss who ends up being manderly
from the first game wants him to pin all
the bombings and attacks on Ark even a
break in adversa life that didn't even
happen according to him all of the
reports will say that the perpetrators
were augmented so the most likely
suspect that the media in public will
assume is Arc this paints Miller is a
bad guy one who is working against what
interpole stands for while also proving
that Arc and their leader tallos Rucker
are innocent it ends up creating a
disconnect between the player and the
people they work for as you feel alone
throughout your whole journey Journey
not just as an Aug in a world where augs
are hated but the fact that the one
organization you work for you can't even
trust and I think the game hammers home
this idea more by making your pilot
incredibly dislikable in every game so
far the protagonist could always rely on
the pilot to side with them even when
the going got tough but now thanks to
Malik being replaced with chicane Jensen
can't even get that you truly feel
isolated within this world and this was
Amplified 10-fold when we were sent to
Golem City I have expected both Miller
and chicane to betray me forcing me to
escape the city on my own for
fortunately they didn't but I couldn't
help shake the feeling that they could
have easily trapped Jensen in this city
and I highly doubt that he would have
made it out on his own a lot of this is
due to the oppressive nature of Golem
city as space is limited and buildings
are stacked taller than the eye can see
it also helps that they had some pretty
easy Source material to work with as
much of the design from Golem City comes
from the real life cowon Wald City a
fascinating piece of architecture that
was designed to fit tens of thousands of
people and one densely packed area it's
also Infamous for having some of the
highest crime ratings of all time since
there were no governing bodies in the
city most people who lived there dabbled
in illegal businesses like selling Black
Market Goods or prostitution and most of
the ruling class were Thugs and gang
members eager to make a quick Buck Golem
city is much the same way as most of the
city's people are suffering and are
often extorted for the little money they
have but the cops don't care it's quite
possibly the best location in the game
though due to its detail and design and
this speaks to a lot of the game's level
design as not only are most locations
larger than the one scen a human
Revolution but the sheer level of detail
in them is unmatched there's a lot more
areas and routes of a player to explore
and Traverse through which adds to the
gameplay Loop and Golem city is the best
place to Showcase this as it takes full
advantage of the new technology to add
more levels to the environment meaning
areas are taller rather than larger
Golem City also provides the player with
a unique Touch of agency towards the
latter half of the level as a placing
these sturdy and more organized cops are
the more chaotic augmented members of
Ark this gets the player to think about
how they want to approach the situation
should they kill these guys not only do
we not know if they're guilty they're
augmented they're like Jensen and
killing them means we're no better than
the cops that butcher them in the
streets it's an incredibly small change
but really changes the flow of the
Gameplay at most the following
conversation with Talos Rucker is a bit
harder to succeed in which isn't much of
a consequence but I am glad that it was
still brought up the game doesn't
penalize you for this that much and you
won't be locked out of content for
killing these people but I still felt
like I needed to spare them just like
the endings of the original DSX only a
good game can get you to do something
like this to actually feel like every
little thing you do has consequences or
that your choices will have actual
meanings to them and man kind of hook me
in well enough that I felt like I needed
to handle it this way reaching the top
of the ivory rusted Tower sees us
meeting with tallos Rucker and as you
would expect he's actually quite the
nice guy in fact we can ask people about
him in Golem City and pretty much all of
them Echo the same thing that he's a
wonderful leader and just doing what he
can for augmented people even his emails
show this too as he's being thanked for
helping someone get neuropathy also
assisting the women as they're often
targets of abuse here in the city he's a
real standup guy but the media paints
him as a villain and it's only going to
get worse as shortly after our
conversation he's killed by some kind of
virus that infects his systems it's
later learned that it was from a drug
called Orchid which will supposedly
eliminate the need for neopine but it's
being made by Versa life which is the
first sign that its properties aren't
real and also the fact that the
Illuminati are controlling the media to
make it seem like the Orchid is a
life-saving drug when it's really
designed to be a bioweapon that controls
the population so as expected the
Illuminati have once again thwarted our
plans as they've planted a man named
marchenko into Ark who secretly works
for the Illuminati so they can kill
Talis Rucker when the time is right
before his pass he gives us a data pad
with info on it that he was looking into
regarding Amo and his organization
reading through it points to JM or
Joseph manderly being the one who
ordered Talis Rucker to be killed just
like the first game though manderly is
under the thumb of the Illuminati
further confirming their involvement
following this Jensen has sent back to
Prague to follow up on a few more leads
which ends up leading into a main quest
decision that I was not expecting during
your time here you'll meet with a man
named Nomad stanic whose daughter
Allison seems to fit the bill of the
train station bomber while this is
happening though Vega got a tip about
Versa life's vault at the Palisade Bank
the problem is that Versa life is
currently double timing it to the banks
they can wipe all the info and Allison
is currently getting ready for the
church's Ascension so if we do this last
she'll be dead by the time we arrive so
we're forced to choose which one to do
and this is one decision where we can't
get what we want we have to pick one or
the other once we find her we realize
that Allison was not the bomber but
someone who made the bombs used during
the attack and that she is also a part
of the Splinter Group with in the church
I mentioned earlier the conversation is
kind of painful to sit through it's
almost like talking someone off a ledge
as she's going to either die by our
hands or by the machines if we don't
help her she like many was affected by
the attack and became increasingly
depressed over what she experienced in
the subsequent discharge from the
military that would follow it's clear
that she is a woman in need of guidance
while I'm not against doing it
spiritually killing yourself in the name
of that God doesn't really sound like
the right idea to me if you instead go
to the bank you'll find a sample of the
Orchid virus in a video call between
Megan Reed and Bob pagee Megan seems to
always find her way into controversy as
she is the lead researcher behind Orchid
but like before she has no knowledge of
its harmful effect effects what's
fascinating about Orchid though is that
the research used for the virus is
similar to the one she was using in the
first game meaning this virus is once
again based off Jensen's DNA in fact
he'll be infected by it later only to
not feel anything further alluding to
its origin additionally while not stated
outright the properties of the virus and
the owners of it that being the
Illuminati could also mean that this was
the virus that would later become the
gray death somehow though that's not
even the weirdest item in this vault as
by going into this corner and throwing
an EMP grenade you can get a brief
glimpse of what's inside the Box only to
discover that it's Jensen or at least
something that looks like him this has
created an ongoing theory that the
Jensen we play as a man kind divided is
a clone now I don't claim to be the
owner of the theory nor the method on
how to find it that said what has been
difficult to pin down when it was first
discovered all the info regarding the
theory has been compiled on the game's
Wiki Phantom Page by the user Aus I'll
link to it down below if you want a more
in-depth look as we're only going to be
hitting the broad Strokes here but the
general idea is that this Jensen is a
clone the evidence to support a from a
variety of sources throughout the series
firstly cloning isn't exactly unheard of
as seen by the Dentons in the classic
games which were overseen by the
Illuminati who owns Versa Life As for
the rest at one point in the game you
get a call from David serif who's
looking to catch up and when you talk to
him Jens can mentioned his new
augmentations early on in the game
Jensen goes to a clinic to get his augs
fixed up after that train station
bombing but his mechanic ker found his
new augmentations that not even Jensen
knew about gameplay wise this is just an
excuse to add new augmentations to the
gameplay Loop which are the glitch ones
that appear on screen neither Jensen nor
serif knew about them though according
to Jensen after pansa he was taken to a
clinic in Alaska so they could repair
his body but Jensen doesn't remember
much about his time there as is mostly a
blur after looking into it more sarif
realized that he couldn't find him on
any of the Survivor lists he even tried
looking at the serial numbers since his
original augmentations were made by serf
but he couldn't find those either what
this implies is that the Illuminati made
an exact copy of Jensen with the same
augments in everything and that this
being in the Pod is either the real
Jensen or another clone now we could go
on for hours arguing about this like why
is there a being in the Box in the first
place if it was completely pitch black
or maybe that this was a placeold that
they decided to throw in here with no
real thought behind it what is clear
that the rabbit hole on this Theory goes
deep taking into account cut content
hidden dialogue and a few of the novels
in an ironic twist a series about
conspiracies finally gave the community
their own conspiracy to latch on to
questioning the existence of the
Illuminati or if the gray death was made
by the government has now turned into a
discussion about whether or not the main
character is even real
similarly the community is just as vocal
about it from either side some saying
Jensen is a clone While others pass it
off as nothing more than a hoax it's
incredible how a series like this where
NPC spot all kinds of insane nonsense at
you making you question if what they say
is any truth to it managed to do the
same exact thing with its own Community
although I guess that's what happens
when you go without a sequel for 7 years
minor tangent aside the main reason I
like this section so much is not the
fact that we are possibly playing as a
solid snake version of Adam Jensen while
our big boss sits in the tank it's it's
actually because each Mission provides
the player with an item that can help
them in a future Mission confronting
Allison and getting a high enough
persuasion bonus will give us a signal
jammer something that is completely
useless and takes up space in your
inventory only for it to become useful
right at the end likewise inside the
vault is a safe which contains a sample
of a cure for orchid this will also be
helpful as it can either give you more
time in the final mission or save a life
that will soon be taken not only is it
wonderful to see the game rewarding the
player with these kinds of items but
they're completely optional failing the
speech check and missing the safe means
you don't even receive the item that the
game wanted to give you it's a fantastic
way of rewarding the player but also
making them work for it the feeling of
finding something that's unique would
lose its value if you were given it
simply by doing the quest but as
immersive Sims Go the game wants to
reward those that explore and Mankind
divided does that quite often especially
with this Mission regardless of the
option you pick though each one has
Jensen learn about a facility called
garm which is where he plans to head to
next but before we go just like human
Revolution one of the games DLCs takes
place around this time except it's not
integrated into the main story but
instead through a new menu called Jensen
stories so I figured it be best to run
through it now it's a real damn shame
that this wasn't introduced into the
main story though because slotting it
here would have made my opinion of it a
lot better called Desperate Measures it
sees Jens in investigating who blew up
the train station because yeah we're
still focused on that apparently but the
issue is that it plays out like any
other mission in the game a quick 30 to
40 minute experience except this is a
separate piece of content so we don't
have all of our equipment that's why I
dislike this so much it doesn't speak
extra content to me and I think it's
because it was never meant to be
desperate measures is the only DLC of
the three that's not only free but was
available day one if you watch my video
on Mass Effect 3 then you might know
where this is going as we have yet
another javic situation on our hands for
those who don't know Mass Effect 3 an
RPG made by biare had day one DLC in the
form of a new companion called javic it
was immediately met with criticism due
to its price and that it was DLC that
was available the day the game was live
which begs the question of why they
didn't just add it to the game well it
was learned that due to the esrv rating
that goes on during development the team
realized that they wouldn't be able to
get the game out on time for the rating
and subsequent release so while the game
was being raided leaving them with
little too they decided to restructure
his entire introductory mission that it
would flow well with how the game was
going to end up he was always envisioned
to be a part of the full game but due to
time constraints the team had to make
some Cuts this is like it would happen
here as it's such an odd piece of
content to add is something extra as it
plot not only follows a lead in the main
quest but it really is just a quest it's
no different than if they just took out
any of the missions we've already talked
about and then made that a separate
download the only important bit of
information though is that we do learn
that this guy's brother-in-law is the
bomber and that's about it as a separate
piece of content it's obviously pretty
bad but imagining how the game would
flow with this as a part of the main
quest does make me feel a bit better
about it while we're here though we
might as well talk about the two other
DLC and we're approaching the end of
this game very soon and trust me these
next two are much better the first of
the two is system Rift which is supposed
to serve as a prologue to breach another
game mode we could play alongside
mankind divided System rift's main
character outside side of Jensen is
Pritchard which was a nice surprise he
needs to break it to the Palisade Bank
the same one we just broke into earlier
but this time go deeper so we can find
information on a company called the
santow group now for being open and
honest most of this scene here is not
too important as the ending is what
really matters as it ends with Jensen
accidentally opening a rift into the
neural subnet causing hackers all over
the world to go inside and search for
all the dirty hidden vials that the
place keeps hidden and we play as one of
those hackers in the Breach game mode
still I did enjoy the gameplay though
and the few characters we meet like
Shadow child were nice enough to listen
to I can see why Pritchard likes her
though as she has equally good taste in
games as a side objective from her is to
place this statue on someone's desk
which is a model of Garrett from Thief
which on that note I wonder how much of
thief inspired this DLC as it feels like
a proper Thief level but in a DSX
context much of thief is spent going
through massive castles and manners
coming through each floor hallway and
room from top to bottom to find all the
treasure and while system Rift doesn't
have you do that much in this area going
through the six or seven levels of this
bank with very little equipment to cling
to as a backup reminded me quite a bit
of th level design much of my time was
spent walking around people rather than
taking them out one by one as I just
didn't have the resources to commit to
that play style the DLC is also long
enough that it doesn't feel like a total
waste to not have your augmentations
roughly doubling the length of the
previous one overall system Rift is
quite solid it adds a very complex level
for the player to explore and new types
of enemies like ones I can see through
your cloak augment it's a nice piece of
DLC but I can't say that it's the best
though many would tell you a criminal
past is the best DLC in the game and
they are not wrong it's so good that
it's worth getting the season pass just
for this it first places Jensen in a
Maximum Security Prison while he
recounts his time there to the task
Force's therapist he was sent here under
cover to find another one of their
agents because there was a tip that a
terrorist attack was soon to come and
this agent was the only one with the
details on whether or not that was true
so Jensen has to act as a prisoner to
find his way to his contact but as soon
as he enters he's given a suppression
drug that removes his augment
capabilities so now augs no equipment
and locked in a prison talk about a
start but the good ideas keep flowing as
the DLC has a surprising amount of
choices for such a short experience one
of the first people you'll meet is this
doctor who will give you a pill that
supposedly removes the suppression
effect the guards placed on you if you
refuse then you can't regain your
augments but don't worry you have
another chance to take the pill later
alternatively you could use this altered
bio cell that will have the same effect
except you'll lose Health every time you
use it due to you're not taking the pill
however you can give this bio cell to a
prisoner named flossy who points you in
the direction of another inmate named
red shoes giving him the bio cell makes
the rest of the game easier as
eventually the prisoners will stage a
riot and if you gave up the bio cell the
prisoners are able to overtake most of
the guards for a 2-hour DLC there is an
insane amount of choices here and those
are just the bigger ones as there's even
small or less significant choices like
this one inmate who can trade you a
multi-tool for some booze and for the
player someone who has no equipment a
multi-tool sounds like Ambrosia or even
this maintenance Locker which has a
different blocks jumpsuit in it letting
you walk through that block with ease as
without it the guards would shoot you on
site outside of the gameplay there is
also a fairly interesting narrative
going on here the head Warden of the
prison Sanger is working with a group
called the junkyard Who harvest
augmented bodies for spare parts and
then sell them on the black market well
Stinger realizes that a few dead
prisoners wouldn't be seen as a problem
to anyone outside of the prisoners
themselves so he sometimes provokes them
into doing violent things only to kill
them after followed by dumping their
bodies off to the junkyards they can
profit off the scrap dog mens the final
part of this DLC has you trekking
through a war torn prison covered in
bodies from all sides while Jensen
attempts to escape with the other agent
and just like the previous DLC I found
that not attacking at all was better
than taking out the guards some stealth
as there are numerous high level enemies
such as ones with helmets or the ones
with full-on power armor that any kind
of Weaponry you could have found would
still not be nearly enough to take them
all down by that metric it's a pretty
hard DLC probably the hardest level in
this game really but dying is not only
expected but it has its own bit of flare
to it as well as the game takes a page
out of Prince of Persia sands of time
like the DLC Sands of Time narrative is
being told by the prince to someone else
so the Prince can't die in the story or
otherwise he wouldn't be here to tell it
so whenever you do die in the game it
plays off deaths and failures as the
prince misremembering the story
similarly whenever you fail the
therapist can be heard correcting Jensen
saying things like Jensen that's not
what happened try again from the
beginning so Jensen restarting from the
beginning is like the player restarting
the checkpoint it's a small but very
neat touch to add to the game which just
shows how much love was put into this a
criminal past is without question an
amazing DLC while it doesn't tie to the
main story in any way it's a Wonder ful
bite-sized adventure to take part in and
if you play the DLCs after the main game
is over this will be the final piece of
content you experience from the game and
the series and I can't think of a better
way to end it than this the reason I say
that is because from here on out things
are going to start getting Rocky and
garm is really the Cal before the storm
that's because the gar facility is so
much shorter than I thought it was going
to be it starts with Jensen being
ambushed by marenko who then injects him
with the Orchid but given the Orchid was
made from his DNA he's unaffected by it
so they just dumped him outside and also
left left all of his gear on him too bit
of a strange start where the rest of the
mission has been trying to escape the
facility and I do admit this was quite
fun as the guards that stalk the halls
of the Shadow operators from the first
mission they are deadlier and more
advanced than any other group in the
game thus far and they can be quite
difficult to slip around even with the
cloak augment the problem comes right
after when Jensen calls shicane to pick
him up and the two leave so we went to a
facility got ambushed and said well [__]
there goes our plan and then left what a
waste of a quest there was so much to
explore here but they just used it as a
quick 20-minute escape sequence to be
fair to the game marchenko and Company
being here is worth investigating which
is what we're going to be doing directly
after this but I vividly remember
getting to the end and just thinking wow
I can't believe it was over this quickly
it's just such an odd Mission from start
to finish Upon returning from his
vacation Jensen realizes that Prague is
now under martial law just like the
first game police will be patrolling the
streets shooting anyone who disobeys
including us this poses a bit of a
problem for the player if they want to
finish up the game side quests as you'll
have to be traveling around the city
just to complete them it's here in
Prague though where we investigate a few
more leads one of which leads us to the
Dali headquarters a sort of organized
crime family from them we get to learn
that they're trying to Target the Safe
Harbor convention in London which is
where the game's finale Begins the
reason this event is so important is
because the lead speaker Nathaniel Brown
has been campaigning to veto the human
restoration act but the Illuminati wants
it to pass so they plan on attacking the
convention and spinning the story so
that it passes this level includes quite
a fun Min game within it which is to
neutralize all the Illuminati memb
posing his guards but getting caught
skips right to the final mission now to
be fair killing all of them will go to
the final mission anyway but I like that
the game added this as an option this
feeling that you screwed up and now have
more problems on your hands plus
attacking a guard in plain sight will
alert the partygoers so you have to take
them all out without anyone's seeing you
I honestly had to get quite crafty with
this one such as tasing this civilian
because he wouldn't leave the bathroom
or specifically taking out this guy
behind the couch that it could hide the
body no matter what happens though
you'll then be met with a choice which
will lead to an ending and for the first
time in a long time time we don't have
to press a button to get that ending the
Illuminati have planned two attacks
they're going to poison the wine that
Brown and his delegates are drinking
which will kill them if we don't get to
them first all while marenko is being
ordered to blow up the nearby
residential Towers potentially killing
thousands in the process your ending
however isn't based on this decision but
rather how fast you are completing them
saving the delegates and stopping the
bombs gets you one ending failing both
gets you another and achieving a mixed
outcome results in two more for grand
total of four possible outcomes and
while the game doesn't mention this you
are on a timer as you have roughly 10
minutes to complete them or you'll fail
unfortunately this means we can't
discuss the endings as in depth as we
did before since there really isn't much
to go over you either save them or you
don't still the actual Mission itself
isn't that bad as it finally lets you
use those items you picked up earlier as
the Orchid can be used to save Miller or
the delegates if you were too late and
the signal jammer can be used to destroy
the bombs before they explode you can
also find Marko's kill phrase on red
desk and use it on him which like the
original game skips the fight entirely
plus it also reveals a shocking
Revelation to the player and that's that
Miller was never the bad guy all along
this whole time I thought he had some
kind of plan to get rid of us and I feel
like most players experienced that too
only for the game to reveal that Miller
was just a regular guy who wanted to do
good and that made me equally sad and
annoyed that I thought of him as my
enemy when he was really just trying to
do his best to do some good in the world
even though he did follow the order that
came down from manderly you could tell
he didn't want to and that he was only
doing it to Plate the higher ups shaane
is still a [__] and still hates
augmented people but Miller was someone
I wrongfully assumed was against me and
it sucks to see him die like this that
said the endings of mankind divided are
widely regarded as some of the worst in
the series and it's also something I
agree with a lot of Y however has
nothing to do with the actual game and
more so the company behind it firstly
regarding the endings while stopping
both attacks is the best outcome as long
as you save Brown you still end up with
a good ending as while thousands may
have died he was able to stop the bill
from passing having him die in either
outcome means it passes without
opposition and failing to stop the bombs
along with that it's just the icing on
the mechanical cake the following scene
is then split into two segments the
first one being being about the actual
ending itself echoing much of what I
just said with the second half being
related to the other choices we made for
example if you chose the heist then a
news report about a break-in would show
on screen but if you talked with Allison
the news of her arrest will be there
instead likewise doing certain side
quests like teaming up with Sam's dad
will also appear there too this one
specifically was rather interesting as
the reports talk about a new group who
appeared after Sam's dad left Prague
called silhouette the same one from the
first game led by Chad dummier who would
eventually team up with nikolette
declair to restart the alum naughty it's
admittedly a nice time to the previous
games but the problem is exactly what
I've shown you nothing was answered in
these endings and like the gar facility
it feels like we were just getting
started mankind divided like its
predecessor once again gives the
Illuminati and now the Juggernaut
Collective little screen time to feel
present in the story at all and the game
itself feels like it was cut short like
the attack on Brown was supposed to be
the climax but in this case it was the
resolution it feels like the series
wasn't done and that it had more to say
the after credit cut scene even alluded
to this as we learn that the Illuminati
know who Jensen is and that they they
are not only anticipating his eventual
meeting with the jerau collective leader
Janis but that the therapist working for
the task force has been a part of the
Illuminati this whole time if you view
it as the second game in a Trilogy a
hypothetical Adam Jensen Trilogy then it
feels a lot better the story is going
somewhere certain story threads have
opened up such as the Juggernaut
Collective and the eventual conflict
between Jensen and the Illuminati is all
but inevitable but if you instead view
it as a singular game especially one
that is the end of a series then all the
impact is gone it's no longer story
beats that will be answered but threads
left unspun questions that only leave
the player with interpretations and some
even less so now that's not to say that
just because it wasn't going to be the
finale that it's exempt from criticism
because even without that the game's
endings don't resolve anything in fact
most of this game doesn't resolve
anything we are no closer to stopping
the Illuminati and we haven't moved
anywhere in the plot at all Jensen once
again tries to stop the Illuminati only
to either fail or hold them back at Bay
a little longer in honestly I would have
been fine with that too because numerous
trilogies have done the exact same thing
both god of war and Mass effect were
designed just like this the first games
were made to set the tone and introduce
major characters at play and while there
was more to come the games felt complete
enough to be their own finales the
second games on the other hand ramped up
the intensity and ended with a clear
goal in mind letting the player know
that the second game was only there to
set up the final conclusion Kratos
versus the gods of Olympus Commander
Shephard versus the rapers and what
could have been Jensen versus the
Illuminati mankind divided really did
divide the community with these endings
and that well and truly sucks because
Idol Montreal seem Keen Onex in this
series not just with other games but
other media too following the release of
human Revolution numerous pieces of
content were made for the series
including two novels two novellas three
Comics mankind divided in its three DLCs
and three spin-off titles DSX the fall a
DSX game but on mobile DSX go a mobile
puzzle game and DX breach a freestand
alone version of the game mode that
exists in mankind divided they even
attempted to go outside the Realms of
entertainment as DSX teamed up with open
bionic a prosthetic limb company to make
a skin that looks like Adam Jensen's arm
so it's clear the idos Montreal wanted
to take the series to new heights but
Square Enix shut them down while its
initial release was successful its
following weeks dip below Human
Revolution and it seems like these low
sales what contributed to the end of the
series even though according to their
2016 fiscal report both mankind divided
and Final Fantasy 15 were explicitly
mentioned to have helped them earn a
positive return on their Investments as
a result Square Enix idos Montreal work
on what they considered to be more
profitable projects like Shadow with a
Tomb Raider Marvel's Avengers and
Guardians of the Galaxy yes DSX died
because Square Enix had them create
Marvel Avengers the game that flopped on
release and can't even be bought anymore
as the servers were shut down and the
game was pulled from digital storefronts
in September of this year to be fair to
Square Enix though a Marvel game is
profitable there is no doubt about that
but the way they handled it wasn't the
right way at the very least the
spin-offs we did get were okay DSX the
fall was an attempt by idos Montreal to
bring back the DSX formula from Human
Revolution to mobile and they did
succeed in doing so for being a mobile
title there is a lot of detail in the
environments and most of the characters
look pretty solid too some of the
gameplay systems are a little puzzling
though like the fact that there is a
universal vendor in your inventory
allowing you to buy anything whenever
you want which while convenient it does
take away from the gameplay as I find
the fun of an immers SYM to be about
using the tools you have or lack thereof
many times I would find myself hoarding
cash just to wait for the right moment
to spend them like buying an EMP grenade
when a robot appears or buying Health
stems and painkillers when blow on
health it's not a very interesting
system but by far its worst sin is that
it's simply not finished not in the
sense that it's buggy but that it's just
literally not complete the fall has four
missions according to the wiki but they
are very generous about what counts as a
mission as the first as you go through a
tutorial disguises a stealth mission to
understand the basics before talking
with some of the crew on a plane and
then having a conversation with a woman
named Anna in your apartment that is
three out of the four missions the game
has Panama City the first location to
provide an open expore level with a few
side quest sprinkled in is also the last
to put it another way it'd be as if
Jensen went to Prague but right before
he goes to Gollum City the game ends
that's how jarring it was to play the
fall because there was clearly more than
what we got as the final shot of the
game even has the to be continued
plastered all over the screen the fall
is basically a full-priced full release
demo for a game that hasn't come out yet
which is a shame because the plot was at
least going somewhere Ben zton is the
protagonist this time around who is also
the main character in a novel in fact
this game is a sequel to that novel so
yeah have fun keeping track of this
story but it first follows him being
recruited to the tyrants that spec op
group we killed back in human Revolution
and all the members are here too namir
yel and Barrett this mission is a
flashback though as Ben eventually
betrays the group once he finds out that
namir was the one who got his men killed
back when he was in the military during
an operation Rainbird the rest of the
game is spent with this girl Anna who is
also part of the same novel as Ben who
are on the run from the tyrants the fall
also introduces Alex Vega from mankind
divided making this game her debut
appearance but there was clearly some
work on her model in between releases as
she looks much different here in the
fall the final mission has been escaping
Panama with Vega before a man named Sam
appears who is one of the men Ben saw
die during operation Rainbird so the
game is setting up a conflict between
Ben and the tyrants while also
introducing Vega which probably would
have explained how she went from Pilot
to jugg a collective member before
revealing the plot twist that one of
Ben's men is not only alive but also
join the tyrants as well to hunt him all
things considered it's got a solid
foundation but that's where the game
ends there was never an Australia level
like the game promised the fall ends
right here it seems like they were going
to drip feed these episodes over the
coming weeks and months like Telltale
does with their games but due to the
poor reception the whole project was
canned which makes the Fall's reputation
even worse as it's not even a finished
game breach on the other hand is
actually quite fun but I was also
predisposed to like it because of its
gameplay loop as mentioned before breach
is based around the breach Jensen made
in that system Rift DLC and now we play
as one of the hackers or rippers in this
case are going into the neural net and
looking for info that bigger companies
want to keep hidden to do that we are to
hop into a level and extract data from
these columns before exiting the level
each one has a certain criteria like
collecting fragments or killing a
certain number of guards and the game
does its best to try to lay on the
difficulty by introducing more complex
levels harder enemies and even modifiers
like taking more damage or having your
health drain constantly throughout the
level the story for this game though is
incredibly light as that brief summary
at the beginning of this section is the
story the whole point of this game is to
complete these levels and then that's it
the fun comes from repeating levels to
get higher scores and finishing
additional challenges each level has an
all data score and timer added to it so
let assume that you'll try to fully
complete a level rather than just doing
the bare minimum sometimes you won't be
able to complete them just yet so you're
encouraged to come back when you have
better equipment like in this example
where I have to kill this giant brute
type Enemy at the time I only had a
pistol so I need to get a bit crafty and
throw these explosive Cubes at it to win
later if I ever get a rocket launcher or
some high-powered sniper I could
probably forget that strategy and just
take the fight to it right away I say
later though as I still haven't found
those weapons due to the game's RNG
system either by activating reward nodes
on the network map or by buying them in
the in-game shop you could acquire
booster packs or Loop boxes that contain
all kinds of different items from
currencies to weapons to practice kits
there is no end goal here in breach it's
just fully completing every challenge in
every level and even then you can
continue far past that too as each one
has a global leaderboard for score and
speed letting you compete with other
players as you would expect though most
of the top scores are hacked which is
ironic given this is a game about
hackers competing to be the best hacker
so I guess that fits but most of the top
scores are legit as odd as it is to say
though coming from someone like me the
story is actually the weakest part of
the game and I kind of wish didn't even
exist in the first place at certain
points the game attempts to interject
some kind of narrative into what you're
doing by having you uncover secret info
that clients want which in gameplay
terms is just doing the missions we're
already doing but this time with
motivation these are fine but these text
conversations you have in between the
levels completely slow down the pace of
the game I can commend the team for
trying to give at least some minor
reason for playing but personally L I
just enjoyed the gameplay I didn't need
an explanation just throw me back in and
I'll run the gauntlet again I'll be
honest I had a fun time playing breach
because I'm obsessed with these speedrun
style games I love Mirror's Edge back
when it was released 15 years ago and
I've been recently replaying the ghost
Runner games cuz it to wants you to
continue far past the credits so you can
improve your time breach is like that
but on a more bite-sized scale instead
of spending 15 plus minutes going to a
level most require only a few seconds
many of the top times are less than five
and even the times on these levels are
as low as 7 or 12 seconds it's a
fast-paced game about getting levels
done as fast as possible so the game
only stops once you do once you've
determined that this is the fastest you
could possibly go breach doesn't have a
deep amount of complexity in its
narrative like the rest of the series or
the immerses and qualities of its
gameplay but it's not meant to breach is
a separate stand alone spin-off that was
trying to be different and honestly I
really enjoyed
it the reason I covered these games now
as opposed to earlier in the video is
because I played these games last just
like they were presented in this video
and while I did have fun it felt like I
was doing just whatever I could to play
Dex I didn't want to stop playing the
series and just like the magic show I
was able to live in Blissful ignorance
for a little while longer with these
spin-offs but at some point I had to
come back to reality and realize that
the series was already done and that
there hasn't been another day of sex in
over 7 years but don't let this distract
you from what we've already spent a
couple hours talking about if there is
one thing I've learned being alive this
long is that you should cherish the
things you have and be thankful you even
had them in the first place dex's future
may be an eternal limbo and we may never
get that ending that the players and The
devs Wanted but despite this we got a
solid amount of fantastic games along
the way the original DSX is still one of
the most important and greatest games of
all time and in its wake jump started
one of the most iconic genres in gaming
Invisible War while they stepped down
was at least ambitious often times too
ambitious but it was a vant attempt to
market the game to a new audience Human
Revolution is still my favorite of the
bunch but even without my personal
biases as the name suggests the game was
revolutionary bringing that classic DSX
feel to a more modern audience and
actually succeeding in doing so and
Mankind divided it has easily some of
the best gameplay and level design in
the whole series by taking what made the
previous game great and evolving it into
something better the series isn't
perfect but it's damn good and one that
I would recommend anyone pick up as
there isn't too many games out there
that let you experiment the way DSX does
and even the ones that do don't always
reach the Peaks this series achieves all
you need to do first is jump down that
rabbit hole and experience it for
yourself I did and you should too thanks
for
watching thank you all for watching
today and I hope you enjoyed it's nice
to finally be making another series
video like this I went a bit longer than
I wanted to without that kind of video
mainly due to last quarter's new
releases but I finally found some time
to make another entry if you ever want
any updates on what video is next or how
close the video is to being done then
feel free to turn on notifications as I
keep all of you updated on the community
tab constantly as always like the video
if you enjoy and subscribe if you're new
thank you to my returning viewers of
coming back to another video and take
care everyone goodbye